Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
LUL
Henrik2017, moin. Der Bada ist auch da.
Ein Kollege auf der Arbeit heißt Henrik.
Ich glaub nicht, dass ihr was miteinander zu tun habt, aber er fällt mir nur gerade irgendwie ein.
LUL
Windows hat mich eben wieder übelst abgefuckt, Leute.
Ja, so neu ist das nicht. So neu ist das nicht. Twitch Prime, ja Twitch Prime gibt's noch.
Twitch Prime gibt sowas von. Gestern erst jemand subscribt auf Twitch mit Prime.
Ich weiß, was das funktioniert.
Windows-Settings haben mich immer wieder übelst abgefuckt.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, wir probieren einfach nochmal eine neue Linux-Distribution aus im Livestream.
Tains auf Stufe 1, 6 Monate, aiaia. Aber richtig hardcore, aiaia.
Das war's, soweit ich gelesen hab.
Oh, das ist wieder so ne Musik. So ne Musikstream, der sich nicht entscheiden kann, ob er laut oder leise sein möchte.
Was ist am Ende mit Poppo erst rausgekommen?
Wenn man ein vorkonfiguriertes Ubuntu haben will, war das ganz okay. Das, was die versprochen haben auf ihrer Website, war etwas sehr vollmundige Versprechung.
Bisschen übertrieben.
So, und so wie es aussieht, müssen wir heute zwei Sachen ausprobieren, nämlich, oder zumindest mal angucken.
Man kann sich eine Ultimate-Edition kaufen für 39 Euro, da verzichte ich mal drauf.
Sondern wir müssen die Lite-Edition und die Core-Edition downloaden, weil das eine hat einen Minimal-Desktop, der sich wohl auch für VMs ganz gut eignet.
Und das andere ist wahrscheinlich ein stinknormales Gnome 3.
Gucken wir mal. Zumindest, die bewerben mir das Ganze auch relativ großartig, toll das ist, auf ihrer Homepage.
Ich bin da ein bisschen skeptisch, ich meine, die schreiben mir zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie...
Okay, Solid ist es, das Ding basiert auf Ubuntu, Ubuntu ist relativ stabil, dass es resistent gegenüber Viren ist.
Es ist halt ein Linux auf dem Desktop, das ist per Default kein großartiges Ziel von Viren.
Runs fast on all computers and new, das probieren wir mal aus, also wer noch so einen Computer am Start hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der neue Linux darauf installiert.
Hier, das hier meine ich, das ist ein bisschen sehr weit ausgeholt.
Und zwar, sie schreiben hier, vollständig Microsoft Office-kompatibel, Professional Photo Editing.
Also mir, ganz ehrlich, mir fällt unter Linux nichts ein, was voll Microsoft Office-kompatibel ist.
Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen, nicht mal Microsoft Office selber ist Microsoft Office-kompatibel.
Deswegen habe ich so meine Zweifel, das ist mein, es wird LibreOffice sein im Endeffekt, was sonst, die haben alle LibreOffice drauf, ja.
OpenOffice, die Chinesen haben WSP, WPS, Kingsoft Office haben die immer drauf.
Aber nachdem ja noch nicht mal Office selbst mit Office-kompatibel ist, habe ich so meine Frage.
Oder aber, Guldilo, der könnte recht haben, vielleicht sagen sie einfach, du kannst Office 365 verwenden, aber das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Moin, Premader, was ich auch ein bisschen sehr geschönt finde, ist diese Aussage hier, da habe ich auch ganz große Zweifel, ob das stimmt.
Professional Photo Editing Software, also, darauf wird garantiert kein neues Photoshop laufen, garantiert nicht.
Das kann ich euch sagen, so sicher wie das Abend in der Kirche, dass darauf kein Photoshop laufen wird.
Ich bin mir nämlich noch nicht mal sicher, ob es überhaupt irgendwie mittlerweile einen, wie auch immer geart, einen Hack gibt, um dieses Adobe-Klauzeug unter Linux laufen zu lassen.
Wir können ja mal gucken gerade, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich.
Also anscheinend nicht.
Play on Linux, Play Creative Cloud. Script only does not work.
Und dann mit Wine, wahrscheinlich läuft es irgendwie mehr schlecht als recht.
Und viele Sachen in Photoshop würden wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, zum Beispiel hat Photoshop ja schon seit einer geraumten Zeit, oder die meisten Grafikprogramme haben ja mittlerweile schon ein bisschen GPU Acceleration,
was in Wine unter emulierten Verhältnissen wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird.
Kann es sein, dass der Stream Aussatz er hat wegen meinem Download?
Du hast ja schon mal gesehen, ok, dann werben sie noch mit unzähligen Apps, Games vorinstalliert, mal gucken, und Steam, wobei Steam halt auch unter einem Ubuntu nicht sonderlich schwierig zu installieren ist.
Gut, damit werben alle, inwieweit es stimmt, wissen wir nicht, die Chancen stehen ganz gut, weil es im Endeffekt ein Ubuntu Rescan ist.
So, kompatibel mit Documents, Musik, Foto, was auch immer.
You can even run many Windows Apps using Wine, ok Wine ist anscheinend auch schon standardmäßig dabei, da probieren wir mal aus.
Es ist besonders einfach, zugänglich für alle Leute, es ist super flexibel, man kann es neben Windows und MacOS installieren, ja gut, das kann man mit jedem Linux machen, das ist jetzt nichts.
So, und deswegen auch das Streamtitel, es macht meine Computer besser.
Welche Linux Distribution würdest du einem Windows Umsteiger empfehlen?
Es ist die Frage, inwieweit er sich mit seinem Computer beschäftigen will.
Wenn er wirklich einfach nur Basics der Sachen verwenden möchte, und es irgendwie noch halbwegs ähnlich zu einem Windows bedienbar soll, dann soll er einfach Linux Mint nehmen.
Ubuntu kann er auch nehmen, im Prinzip kommt er aufs gleiche raus.
Ich würde sagen, Linux Mint, wenn du dich ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigen möchtest, dann bin ich ja für Manjaro.
Mario Kart.
Hi Max fragt, der Colvin Vortex fragt, macht es Sinn, meine Festplatte zu verschlößen, wenn ich kein TPM Modul habe?
Ja, unbedingt macht das Sinn, du brauchst kein TPM Modul, um deine Festplatte zu verschlößen.
Wozu?
Ich habe meine Festplatte schon, ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen Jahrzehnte verschlüsselt, aber das reicht noch nicht mal.
Jahrzehnte, die Mehrzahl ist schwierig, aber ich habe meine Festplatte schon ewig, über 10 Jahre verschlüsselt.
12, 13, 14 Jahre, TrueCrypt, VeraCrypt.
Ein riesen Vorteil hat das, wenn man seine Festplatte verschlüsselt.
Man kann seine Festplatte bedenkenlos wegwerfen, das ist für mich auch der riesen Vorteil an einem voll verschlüsselten System.
Ich kann eine SSD nehmen aus meinem Rechner, ich kann ihnen einen Rucksack nehmen, ich stecke ihn irgendwo mit hin, ich kann die einfach auf den Müll schmeißen und es kann kein Mensch jemals mit dem Inhalt was anfangen.
Also zumindest nicht so lange das Universum existiert oder jemand einen Quantencomputer salonfähig macht.
Was hältst du von Apple T2 Security Chip? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der macht.
Gibt es ein Command für den Chat, um mit seinen Konalpunkten zu flexen?
Also wenn Nightbot etwas eingebaut hat, dann ja, wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Wie verschlüsselt man seine Festplatte mit Windows?
Die Frage, die du dir erstmal stellen musst ist, wenn du deine Festplatte mit Windows verschlüsseln willst, willst du sie mit Boardmitteln verschlüsseln oder willst du sie mit Open Source Tools verschlüsseln?
Oder ist es dir scheißegal?
Boardmittel haben natürlich den Vorteil, du musst nichts zusätzlich installieren und sind besser integriert, wobei man halt sagen muss, Veracrypt ist auch nicht schwierig zu installieren und ist auch ziemlich easy.
Ich habe einen, äh nicht Ubiqui, Ubiqui habe ich für Verschlüsselungskram.
Verwende ich aber nicht, habe ich mir irgendwann mal gekauft, aber verwende ich irgendwie nicht.
Wobei das eigentlich eine coole Sache ist, ja und es gibt auch eine ziemlich gute Alternative.
Nicht Googles Alternative, wie hieß das denn das andere?
Solo, Solo Keys? Nee.
Ich weiß nicht, aber die Dinge sind eigentlich ganz cool als zwei Fakta, Alternifizierung.
Es ist halt nicht mehr komplett Open Source die ganze Ubiqui Geschichte, deswegen hatte ich mich auch mal nach Alternativen umgeguckt.
Ubico, war das das?
Was auch immer, egal.
Also um jetzt mal zurück zu kommen, Warning, machen wir, machen wir, wie viel Festplattenplatz haben wir eigentlich?
Genug, wir können auch die Pop-OS Installation wegschmeißen, falls ich ihn noch habe.
So aber vorher muss ich noch auf ein paar weitere Fragen im Chat eingehen, geht da eben ein paar Sachen, nee habe ich schon alles weggeschmissen.
Und zwar die erste Frage, die noch offen ist, wie man seine Festplatten verschlüsselt unter Windows, entweder mit BitLocker, das ist standardmäßig dabei, habe ich aber noch nie gemacht.
Ich verwende immer das da.
Ich verwende immer das, das ist der einzige Software aus Frankreich, den ich verwende.
Ich verwende immer das hier, das ist total simple.
Du downloadest das einfach, übrigens du kannst natürlich auch das Schöne an Werraquip, du kannst das Ganze auch unter Mac und Linux öffnen, wenn du willst.
Ja und richtig, BitLocker gibt es nicht in der Windows Home Version, das stimmt.
Kann man damit auch die Systemplatte verschwenden, ja klar, kannst du.
Du installierst dir das und dann, ich kann es jetzt, ich habe leider keine, habe ich noch eine Windows VM, da könnte ich dir das zeigen, wie das Ganze ausschaut.
Haben wir noch die Windows VM?
Nee, haben wir nicht, da sonst hätte ich es dir gezeigt.
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich easy, wie das funktioniert.
Ich würde vorher immer einen Backup machen, ich würde nicht einfach hier quasi on the fly verschlüsseln.
Mir ist noch nie was passiert, aber ich meine letztendlich ist das ja das, was so ein Verschlüsselungsorganer auch macht, nur dass du standardmäßig den Key für hast.
Die Daten auf deiner Platte sind so nicht mehr lesbar.
Das heißt, wenn irgendwas schief geht, ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt einen Backup zu haben.
Du musst keinen Vollbackup machen, einfach die wichtigsten Sachen, dass man im Zweifelsfall neu installieren kann.
Ich hatte noch nie Probleme, aber man weiß ja nie.
Nee, aber das ist ziemlich einfach mit Werraquip das Ganze zu machen.
Ich glaube, die haben ja sogar, hier Beginners Tutorial, da steht es doch sogar.
Du hast zwei Varianten.
Hast du das mit Werraquip und dem BSI mitbekommen?
Nee, was ist da?
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
BSI musste Audit-Ergebnisse zu TrueCrypt veröffentlichen.
Okay, was war da?
Unveröffentlich gelassen, ah, die haben es unveröffentlich gelassen, so nach dem Motto, dass man das theoretisch ausnutzen kann, wenn man möchte.
Stimmt, man weiß ja bis heute nicht, warum TrueCrypt dicht gemacht hat, oder TrueCrypt nicht mehr gibt.
Laut hat Sicherheitskenntnisse über TrueCrypt, es sei denn, nee gut, das ist ja von dem Backdoor jetzt noch relativ weit weg, Sicherheitserkenntnisse über TrueCrypt, blablabla.
Also von dem Backdoor steht jetzt da nichts, ich meine, natürlich ist es auch schlecht, wenn man die Verschlüsselung einfacher als durch Prudforce entschlüsseln kann.
Aber Backdoor ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben jetzt genannt, das wird zu nennen.
Nee, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt, aber wundert mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Ich denke aber, man ist auf jeden Fall auf einem guten Weg, wenn man seine Platte mit VeraCrypt verschlüsselt hat, im Vergleich zu einfach nur Plaintex.
Wie gesagt, es mag vielleicht nicht dagegen schützen, wenn es jetzt irgendwie der Geheimdienst auf jemanden abgesehen hat, aber ich behaupte mal, der Geheimdienst hat es auf die wenigsten von uns abgesehen, sondern es geht einfach um Komfortgeschichten.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es super, dass ich meine Festplatte mitnehmen kann, ich finde es super, dass ich meine Festplatte einfach in den Müll schmeißen kann.
Ich bin einfach beruhigt, weil ich weiß, selbst wenn mal einer mein Laptop klaut, dass man mit dem Inhalt zumindest nichts anfangen kann.
Ich meine, auf dem Laptop sind ja auch so Sachen drauf, wie vielleicht irgendwelche, irgendeinen Passport save, den muss man zwar auch erst noch mal zusätzlich entschlüsseln, aber ich meine, allein schon wenn man drankommt, ist schon mal doof.
Irgendwelche Logins, die sind im Browser gespeichert, sind das WLAN-Passport oder solche Geschichten und da ist es natürlich super, wenn man die Platte einfach voll verschlüsselt hat.
Da kann man eigentlich auch nicht viel falsch machen und die Performance ist mittlerweile auch ziemlich gut von einem voll verschlüsselten System, da die CPUs mittlerweile, wenn man AES verwendet, das in Hardware quasi latency-free, bandbreiten, also ohne Einschränkungen großartig verwenden kann.
Also da muss man sich echt keine Gedanken machen, dass das System irgendwie langsam wird.
Genau, und Boss, Baba, so geht das Ganze. Du hast die Auswahl zwischen der Verschlüsselung von einem einzelnen, also du hast drei Sachen zur Auswahl. Du kannst ein Laufwerk verschlüsseln, du kannst eine Datei erstellen, die du dann als Laufwerk in Windows benutzen kannst, also quasi du verwendest ein Laufwerk in Windows, da kannst du alle deine Dateien reinlegen und unter der Haube verschlüsselt es das halt in eine Datei, die irgendwo auf deinem Rechner liegt, oder?
Du kannst eine Vollverschlüsselung von deinem System machen, hier sieht man es ja auch.
Du kannst einen Container erstellen, das ist quasi eine verschlüsselnde Datei, die du dann im Windows Explorer als Laufwerk verwendest, du kannst ein Laufwerk verschlüsseln und du kannst dein komplettes System verschlüsseln.
Muss allerdings klar sein, wenn du dein komplettes System verschlüsselst, dann musst du bei jedem booten, musst du ein Passport eingeben, um deine Festplatte zu entschlüsseln.
Und was ja auch klar sein muss, im Gegensatz zu BitLocker, wo es irgendwelche Hintertürchen gab, gibt, ich weiß nicht ob noch gibt, aber auf definitiv gab, dass Microsoft Passwörter für dich herstellen kann, wenn du hier dein Passwort verlierst, das ist eine Arschkarte, dann ist vorbei.
Passwort weg, Daten weg, du hast keine Chance das irgendwie zu recover.
Es gibt eine RecoverCD, die ist aber nicht dafür gedacht Laufwerke zu entschlüsseln, das ist auch so ein bisschen was, was viele Leute glaube ich am Anfang falsch verstehen, wenn sie RecoverCD oder RecoverUSBstick lesen, der RecoverUSBstick bzw. die RecoverCD ist nicht dafür da Festplatten zu entschlüsseln oder Laufwerke zu entschlüsseln, wenn man das Passwort vergessen hat, das wäre ja bescheuert, dann würde ich verschlüsseln, kann es einfach wieder entschlüsseln, nein, die ist dafür da, wenn die Festplatte beschädigt ist.
Das ist ein großer Unterschied, wenn die Festplatte beschädigt ist oder manche Sachen nicht mehr lesen kann, dann kann ich mit dem Passwort wohlgemerkt und der RecoverCD den Kram wieder herstellen, mit Glück.
So und dann hast du noch eine weitere Variante, die habe ich aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie verwendet, du kannst deine Laufwerke auch verstecken, das heißt du kannst quasi einen Windows drauf installieren
und in diesem Windows nochmal einen Windows quasi verstecken, so quasi YoDog mäßig, du kannst quasi einen Windows installieren und wenn dann, das ist für die Leute mit richtigen Verfolgungsbahnen im Endeffekt,
das ist dafür gedacht, dass du quasi, wenn du verfolgt wirst oder so, oder keine Ahnung, die Polizei oder das Sondereinsatzkommando dein Haus raidet, dann kannst du immer noch sagen und die dich quasi drohen zu erschießen, so nach dem Motto rücke jetzt oder die Mafia kommt zu dir oder was auch immer, so.
Und die drohen dich zu erschießen und dann kannst du sagen, Jungs, Jungs, ich gebe euch das Passwort oder ich zeige euch meinen Rechner und dann bootest du halt deinen Standard Windows und es sieht so aus, als wäre es dein normaler Rechner, aber in Wirklichkeit ist dein richtiges Windows, quasi deine richtige Daten sind in einem hidden Volume.
Ob das jemand wirklich verwendet, weiß ich nicht, ich habe es noch nie verwendet, ich verwende das ganz normale Standard System, Entire System Drive Encryption, das heißt, wenn ich reboote, muss ich beim booten ein Passwort eingeben.
So, genau, kannst du das mal angucken, es sieht komplizierter aus, als es ist, du kannst dir auch ein paar Guides auf YouTube angucken, es ist ziemlich einfach und der Guide sehe ich auch gerade nicht für Vollverschlüsselung, sondern für Laufwerke, also nicht für Laufwerke, für Dateien, also für Dateien mounten als Laufwerke, guck dir mal ein Guide an, es ist ziemlich einfach, ich behaupte mal kann im Prinzip eigentlich jeder.
So, hat denn VeraCrypt einen Vorteil gegenüber Bitlogger, ja gut, wie man es sieht, also wenn es für dich ein Vorteil ist, dass das Programm quasi offen ist, dass es schon mal, zumindest für TrueCrypt einen Audit gab, wobei man jetzt ja gesehen hat, dass das jetzt auch nicht so viel heißen muss, dass es relativ weit verbreitet ist und dass Microsoft kein Passwort rekommendiert hat.
Wenn du die Recovery Option hat, dann ja, also du kannst dir relativ sicher sein, dass wenn du deine Platte mit VeraCrypt verschlüsselst, dass die keiner bis zum Untergang des Universums jemals entschlüsselt, wenn du ordentliche Festplatte hast.
Die machen riesen Fortschritte, was kryptografische Sachen angeht und nicht einfach nur riesen Fortschritte, sondern schon Lichtjahre, lange, weite Fortschritte, wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hast.
Was hast du benutzt, um deine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln? Ich benutze seit über 10 Jahren TrueCrypt bzw. VeraCrypt.
So, ich muss gerade beim Chat runter scrollen.
Da braucht der Trojaner nur noch ein Passwort zu ändern, also einfach ist es nicht ein Passwort zu ändern, aber der Trojaner, der Zugriff der Admin-Rechte quasi hat auf deinem PC, der kann ja alles lesen.
Weil wenn du Windows gestartet hast, nachdem du das Passwort eingegeben hast, also sprich zur Laufzeit ist die Sache ja entschlüsselt, also würde Windows ja nicht funktionieren, also sprich du musst den Rechner schon ausschalten, dass das dann auch sicher ist danach.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt hier jemand durchs Fenster springt und mir die Pistole vor die Nase hält und sagt Max weg vom Rechner und das ganze ist entsperrt, dann kann er da voll Zugriff drauf, gut, ich meine, ich weiß ja nicht was er damit will, aber er hätte voll Zugriff drauf.
Benutzst du VeraCrypt für Windows und Linux? Ne, ich verwende VeraCrypt verwende ich nur für Windows und der Linux verwende ich ganz normal Lux, was eingebaut ist.
Der Crye fragt Max, hast du vor einer Weile, du hattest doch vor einer Zeit einen neuen Server mit der festverläuteten CPU gebaut, gibt es irgendwo eine Teile-Liste? Ja, aber ich weiß nicht mehr wo, wir haben mal eine Teile-Liste gemacht, sieht man bei Geizhals seine gespeicherten Listen?
Vielleicht da? Nass, ist es das? Ja, das ist, wobei, ne, das war mal so eine Idee, was man bauen könnte, aber das ist es nicht.
Ja, aber wenn du konkrete Hardware Sachen wissen willst, jetzt kann ich dir das auch schnell sagen. Wie ist das bei Windows 10 Upgrade? Du musst es ja wieder entschlüsseln, oder?
Das kommt auf das Windows Update an, das letzte Windows Update war kein Problem, der hat keine neue Installation gemacht und lustigerweise das Windows Update davor ging auch, das heißt ich habe die Vermutung, dass Windows Update wohl mittlerweile funktioniert.
Müsste man sich mal schlaumachen, ob das einfach nur Glück war, dass es funktioniert hat, ohne entschlüsseln das letzte Mal, weil das letzte Mal war ganz merkwürdig beim letzten größeren Update.
Ja, Chat, genau. Das letzte Mal war ganz merkwürdig beim letzten großen Update, also nicht das jetzt aktuelle, das war ja keine Windows Update schräg-schräg Neuinstallation, sondern das davor, ich habe es wie immer versucht zu entschlüsseln und Windows Update zu machen, hat ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Dann habe ich es dann einfach wieder verschlüsseln und habe mir gesagt, Windows leckt mich und dann hat es funktioniert. Namen des Boards, Board habe ich das da, das Board habe ich für die 10 Gigabit Karte hier unten drinnen, wenn du auch 10 Gigabit bauen willst und als Gehäuse, aber wie gesagt ich würde es eh nicht wirklich empfehlen, das ist sehr experimentell was wir da gebaut haben.
Also als Gehäuse habe ich das günstigste, das günstigste Rack Mountable Gehäuse genommen mit Wechselrahmen drinnen, also auch jetzt nicht das da habe ich als Gehäuse.
Also das ist nicht das Qualitätswunder, aber man muss halt sagen, dass es das günstigste 10G nach was man sich irgendwie zusammenschustern kann, was ich da gebaut habe.
Meistens X4 oder XFS, allerdings aktuell habe ich auf meiner fetten 4HE Kiste, also das mit den 3x10TB, mein aktuelles Rover den ich hier stehen habe, den ich gerade am ablösen bin, da habe ich ZFS drauf.
Kannst du mal was zu Browsern sagen, warum du zum Beispiel Chromium benutzt? Tja, gute Frage, nächste Frage.
Ich habe glaube ich war angefangen mit Chromium, weil ich nicht wollte, dass ich aus Versehen, ja jetzt lacht mich aus, aber ich wollte nicht aus Versehen Video Streamen über Chromecast auf den Fernsehtrüben.
Das ist jetzt der Chat, also wirklich Chat, was ihr wieder denkt, was ist das für Videos denn, das kann ich jetzt wieder hier haben, Chat, das ist schlimm, schlimm.
Nein, natürlich, natürlich, nein, nein, nein, nur, das ist genauso wie ich bei Torrent nur Linux-Distributionen herunter lade.
Na zumindest, angefangen habe ich, dass ich nicht aus Versehen, nein, das ging überhaupt nicht um irgendwelche Porn-Filmchen oder sonst was, die ursprüngliche Sache war wirklich, dass ich nicht aus Versehen Filme auf den Fernsehtrüben streamen wollte, unabhängig davon welche Filme, weil im Chrome ist es halt so, wenn du irgendwas aufmachst,
sei es irgendwie YouTube, sonst was, wobei, doch, genau, das kann halt durchaus passieren, dass du anstatt Kino-Modus mal hier aus Versehen ein bisschen falsch klickst und schon castest du irgendwelche Sachen auf dein Fernseher, was halt ehrlich gesagt ziemlich doof ist.
Ich habe danach gecheckt, dass man das in Chrome auch deaktivieren kann, aber das ging danach im Update nicht mehr, da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich jedes Mal in jedem Chrome-Update jetzt neu gucken muss, wie ich Chromecast ausschalte, dann mache ich es einfach so, weil manchmal möchte ich ja Chromecast haben, da installiere ich mir einfach Chrome mit Chromecast und Chromium ohne Codex und alles und gut ist.
Was ist denn an dem NAS zu experimentell? Naja, zum Beispiel, dass die 10-Gigabit-Karte, also erstens, dass der PCI-Express-Slot zu langsam ist für 10G, dass eine System-SSD und eine Magnetplatte eigentlich jetzt nicht so der Performance-Burner sind für 10G, ich meine, es ist schneller, es ist, sie bringen mehr, als über 1 Gigabit rübergehen würde, aber von 10 Gigabit sind sie weit entfernt.
Und auch die, ich kann es dir ja mal zeigen, und auch diese Geschichte hier mit, ich habe doch irgendwo mal ein Bild von meinem Server gehabt, vom aktuellen, ich glaube, das habe ich nicht gespeichert, kann das sein?
Ah, hier, da, genau, da ist er. Und auch, dass quasi vom PCI-Express-Slot, wobei Linus Tech Tips macht es ja auch so, haben wir letztens gesehen, dass quasi vom PCI-Express-Slot zur 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkarte hier dieses Erweiterungskabel rübergebt, könnte auch schöner sein.
Haha, anti, genau, nur Linux, natürlich, über Toche, nur Linux-E-Source, warum nicht Firefox? Ah, Firefox ist nämlich auch installiert.
Ich habe Chrome, Chromium, Firefox und Vivaldi. Vier Browser Master Race, beste.
Okay, ich sehe schon, wir kommen hier nicht zur Linux-Installation gerade, aber muss ja auch mal Zeit sein für eine Runde Fragen beantworten im Chat.
Habe ich jetzt, habe ich jetzt hier übersehen? Ah, also, ne. Ich meine, mittlerweile habe ich euch das Bild ja gezeigt, mittlerweile ist das Ganze zu und, gut, da stand dann noch hier in der Ecke auf einem Haufen Müll.
Mittlerweile ist er zu und steht hier rum und ist auch schön beschriftet, aber die High-End-Hardware ist es natürlich nicht, dafür ist es halt gnadenlos günstig, für 250 Euro einen 10-Genas zusammenzuschustern, ist halt auch anspruchsvoll, ja.
So, also, was habe ich übersehen auf dem, im Chat? Welche UniFi Access Points hast du, bei dir bist du zufrieden mit der Reichweite? Ja, das ist richtig nice.
Also, ich habe, ich meine, ich bin am Überlegen, ob ich noch einen dritten dazustelle, ich habe den, ich habe den da, das war der erste, den ich gekauft habe, den da, der ist aber nicht mehr aktuell, ja, der kostet, ähm, da hier so, also den da habe ich, das war der erste, den ich mir gekauft habe.
Das coole an dem ist, und das ist tatsächlich echt enorm praktisch, leider hat Ubiquiti das abgeschafft, und zwar, der hat unten einen USB-Anschluss, und das ist nämlich ganz nützlich, weil du betreibst das Ding ja über PoE, das heißt, es kriegt Strom über, über das Netzwerkkabel, und hier hinten hast du einen USB-Port, den USB-Port haben die mal eingeführt für irgendwelche erweiterbaren Alarmsysteme und sonst was, aber haben es nie verwendet, das heißt,
die neueren Access Points, die haben das nicht mehr, und das coole an dem Port war, ich habe da drüber meinen Raspberry Pi angeschlossen, auf dem die UniFi-Software lief, das war schon ganz praktisch, dass du keinen extra Stecker gebraucht hast, allerdings ist der USB-Port von so unglaublich schlechter Qualität gewesen, weil ich hab's, sonst hab ich das noch nie erlebt, das war das erste Mal, dass ich das erlebt habe, dass der USB-Port einen Wackelkontakt hatte nach zwei Wochen,
weil auf einmal hast du den Tisch, wo das draufgelegt hat, ein bisschen gewackelt, und zack, hat sich der Raspberry ausgeschaltet, und ich dachte erst, das Problem ist das billige China-Kabel, das ist nämlich so ein USB-Stromkabel gewesen, da wo ich mir mal die 50er Box aus China bestellt habe, die ganz billigen, die unter einem Euro, das Kabel, Box, war da dran, und da dachte ich erst, dass das scheiß China-USB-Kabel was kaputt ist, aber nein, der USB-Port hat einen Wackelkontakt,
mir war bis dahin gar nicht klar, dass USB-Ports wirklich Wackelkontakt haben können, also im Port drinnen, was ist das, das ist ein Access-Port, den hab ich einmal, das war der erste, den ich gekauft hab, und jetzt hab ich noch ein Nano-HD, der sieht fast genauso aus, der ist ein Ticken kleiner, nicht viel, so ein bisschen kleiner,
dafür ist der 5GHz-Bereich besser, kostet allerdings auch ein Ticken mehr, also wenn es wirklich rein um die Kohle geht, dann würde ich den nehmen, aber ansonsten, wenn ich mir jetzt neu kaufen würde, würde ich zweimal den da nehmen, ich bin nämlich auch gerade am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht noch einen dritten hole, quasi noch in die andere Ecke vom Haus, nochmal so ein, das einzige Problem, warum ich das nicht mache, ist, ich habe in dieser anderen Ecke im Haus
nicht so ohne weiteres einen Netzwerk-Kabel, da müsste ich erst mir was einfallen lassen, aber das wäre halt auch die Ecke, wo es dann raus zur Terrasse geht, wo es halt cool wäre, wenn da irgendwo an der Wand direkt ein Access-Point stehen würde, ja, so, das sind die Access-Points, die ich hab, welchen Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus soll ich bei VeraCrim wählen, AES, immer AES, und Hardware-Beschleunigung aktivieren?
Flüssigmetallschleim sagt, ich nutze eigentlich nur Firefox, Firefox ist nach wie vor immer auch mein Lieblingsbrowser, ich benutze zwar mittlerweile hauptsächlich, oder öfter Chrome als Firefox, aber Firefox ist trotzdem mein Lieblingsbrowser, klingt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen paradox, ja, ich weiß, aber ist so, Knalli-Beer, Vivaldi, ja, bester, Edge-Chromium, ok, das hab ich noch nie verwendet,
äh, wenn du dreimal 10TB im NAS hast, kein Rate Null, oder wie, wie, warum nicht, warum kein Rate Null? Rate Null ist das Beste, ähm,
gibt's eigentlich schon ARM-Server-Desktop-CPUs? Ja, man kann die ohne Probleme für Server und Desktop jetzt schon verwenden.
Powerline, nee, Powerline suckt, Powerline würd ich nicht verwenden, also ich meine, ich extende doch kein Access-Point mit Powerline, das ist ja schon irgendwie in sich fragwürdig,
kann man das, kann man machen, aber da muss schon sehr, Notlage sehr hoch sein, äh, METSOFINI98, zwei Monate, excellent, Prime-Sub, ups, falsch, so, richtig, ähm,
äh, Mr. Opie, nee, es gibt auch ne Core-On-Lite-Version, die installieren wir jetzt, wo wir grad dabei sind, ich kann das schon mal machen, während ich hier weiter Questions beantworte.
Aber übrigens, nein, das ist ein ZFS-Rate Fünf, also ein ZFS-Rate Eins, was kein Rate Eins ist, sondern ein Rate Fünf, was ich mit den dreimal zehn Terabyte hab, kein Rate Null.
Die neuen Ryzens sollen sich ziemlich gut für Server eignen, also Home-Server. Ja, wenn man die Performance braucht, ist es keine schlechte Idee, also wenn man wirklich Multi-Core-Performance, Multi-Threaded-Performance braucht, zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwie so nen Media-Server mit Transcoding machen will, dann ist ein Ryzen sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Hab ich, ich muss mal kurz gucken, hab ich die VMs eigentlich das letzte Mal gelöscht? Ja, guck mal.
Das ist Ratchet, ja. Du, du, du, du hast, du hast, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich bist du auch ein, ein Viren-Fan. Du sammelst Viren, gibst zu.
Ähm, äh, Linux, was ist denn das, Ubuntu? Ah, passt, das ist im Prinzip eh wurscht.
Ja, wir können auch Ubuntu auswählen, aber das macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied. Die Settings sind eh die gleichen, mehr oder weniger.
Ein Kehr, Kehr nein, vier Kerne pro CPU, ähm, 4G RAM sollten reichen, ich mein, die werben bei den Betriebssystemen damit, dass das alte Computer wieder flott macht, also 4GB RAM sollte da dicke reichen. Nutt, jawoll, weiter, New Disk, 20G reichen zum Testen auch, Single File, Ext, so.
Printer kommt weg, Soundkarte lassen wir dran und, äh, gut ist, Finish. So.
So. Ich hatte auch erst neulich, was, was, der Knallibär schreibt, ich hatte erst neulich festgestellt, dass Windows 10 Pro kein Software-Rate 5 machen kann.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Windows überhaupt Rate machen kann. Äh, gibt's da eine Alternative zu Außer-Storage-Pools? Ah, stimmt, so hieß das, ja. Keine Ahnung. Linux installieren.
Damit ist das alles kein Problem. Äh, so, ISO File. Was wollen wir als erstes ausprobieren? Wir installieren mal die Vollversion, oder? Wir installieren mal die Vollversion und danach installieren wir die Lite-Version.
Oh, auf geht's. Wir haben, ja, ja, Finished. Vor allem, wer nervt nicht rum?
Stretch. Ach komm, was geht das so? Ähm. Oh, Animation.
Welche CPU würdest du für ne Workstation nehmen, wenn du mit einer Workstation auch zocken willst? Äh, entweder ne 3950x oder gleich den Threadripper 3960x. Kommt aber auch ein bisschen aufs Geld an, was man ausgeben will, ne?
Wahrscheinlich reingeldmäßig den 3950x, wobei ja so ein Threadripper mit noch ein bisschen mehr Kern auch nice ist. Ich würd mir aber auf jeden Fall ne AMD CPU reinbauen.
Die neuen Ryzens brauchen auch fast keinen Strom im Idol. Auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger als früher. Ähm, das ist so der einzige Punkt, wo man sagen muss, da ist AMD noch nicht so weit wie Intel, wenn man so im, sagen wir mal, unteren, aber nicht Low-End-Performance-Sektor guckt, dafür sehr stromsparende CPUs haben will.
Da hat Intel mit den Pentium-Silver-Dingern und das sind Atom-Nachfolger, die haben den Pentium-Silver unbenannt, weil Microsoft, äh, weil Intel Fivehead Naming benutzt, ähm, da hat AMD nix wirklich zu bieten in der Richtung.
Das ist eigentlich auch ne super Plattform preisleistungsmäßig. Du kriegst nen Board, du kriegst für 65, 70, 75 Euro nen Board mit, mit, mit aufgelöteter oder quasi mit CPU dabei, die Idol 6 Watt braucht. Ohne was.
Ja, also das ist schon nicht schlecht. Meinung zu Unraid, ich hab's mir mal vor Jahren kurz angeguckt, warum sie da jetzt alle so nen Hype drum machen, ist mir nicht so ganz verständlich. Wahrscheinlich, weil es Linus verwendet. Weiß nicht.
Ich, ich würde jetzt, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wozu ich's verwenden würde.
Wie sieht's mit der neuen CPU bei dir aus? Ich hab's, wie gesagt, nicht bestellt. Okay, installen, wir installieren gleich, wir tryen nicht, wir installieren gleich.
Äh, wenn bei Raid 5 eine Platte abraucht, kann ich die austauschen hab, alle Daten wieder save. In der Theorie schon. In der Praxis kommt's ein bisschen drauf an, wie groß die Platten sind und wie viele Platten du im Raid 5 hast. Also in der Regel ja.
Dafür ist es da, weil wenn das nicht der Fall wäre, müsste man auch kein Raid 5 verwenden. Wo sind wir denn hier überhaupt?
Germany. No dead keys. Ben. Detect. Ja, das macht Ubuntu Abfragen. Genau, press Y. Yes, press O. No, wir sind nicht französisch. No dead keys haben wir.
Also bei Raid 5 sieht's folgendermaßen aus. Der Sinn dahinter ist, wenn du quasi drei Festplatten hast, eine raucht ab, dann kannst du's quasi aus den Informationen, die auf den anderen zwei gespeichert sind, wieder herstellen.
Aber man muss da ein bisschen aufpassen, also wenn man jetzt umso größer die Festplatten werden, umso wahrscheinlicher ist natürlich auch mal, dass so eine Festplatte einen Lesenfehler hat, der nicht dazu führt, dass jetzt quasi das komplette System verreckt, was drauf ist, aber was bei einem Recovery von einem Raid schon problematisch sein könnte, weil bei einem Raid Recovery verlässt sich der Controller ja drauf oder die Software, wer auch immer das macht, dass du wirklich es auch wieder herstellen kannst. Wenn da dann was nicht lesbar ist, ist schlecht, kackt das Recovery ab.
Und umso mehr, also umso größer die Platten und umso mehr Platten man in den Raid 5 packt, umso höher sind die Chancen, dass das Recovery nicht mehr richtig funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn man drei Platten nimmt, dreimal 10TB Platten und so, das ist okay, das kann man machen.
Wenn man da jetzt sagt, okay, ich nehme irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 8 Platten, da würde ich mir schon mal Gedanken machen, ob ein Raid 5 eine gute Idee ist. Eher nicht.
Okay, download Updates while installing, install third party Software Graphics, jawoll, mach. Don't participate in Censors. Nein, wir machen keine Statistiken, continue.
Hat er einen, den ich immer mit der Wärmeentwicklung zu kaufen, also die aktuellen Ryzen CPUs lassen sich sehr gut kühlen.
Okay, das ist der ganz normale Ubuntu Installer, Erase, Install, alles gut, jetzt.
Es wäre sinnvoll, wenn du anzeigen würdest, wie groß die Festplatte ist, die du erkannt hast, aber mach mal, continue. Wir sind in Berlin, Name, Test, Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, oh, das ist fair, fair, huge, das ist kein easy Passwort, das ist fair.
Next, okay, ist ein bisschen abgehackt, gucken wir mal zu, kann ja weiter, weiter Chat-Fragen beantworten, während das installiert.
Nein, denn Ryzen ohne Kühler, jede halbwegs aktuelle Desktop-CPU ohne Kühler mag nicht.
Das ist jetzt kein früher oder gegen Ryzen, wenn du den aktuellen Intel Desktop-CPU nimmst, du kannst selbst, selbst den Raspberry 4 hat Probleme ohne Kühler.
Zwar nicht so extrem, wie es den aktuellen Desktop-CPU von Intel oder AMD hat, aber auch der wird ziemlich warm, wärmer als sie sich so vorgestellt haben am Anfang.
Storage-Pools, Windows hab ich noch nie verwendet, ich weiß auch nicht, mir wieder strebt es auch irgendwie, Windows-Software-Rate zu verwenden.
Gegen AMD-Rate hab ich nix, also meine Lieblingsgeschichte ist ja immer noch ZFS, wenn ich Unterlienungs-Was-Rate-mäßiges machen muss.
ZFS ist einfach nice, von den Features her, die ganze Snapshot-Geschichte, mittlerweile mit der neuen ZFS-Version sogar Verschlüsselung eingebaut.
ZFS ist eigentlich so rund um Sorglos-Paket an Features, allerdings muss man sagen, natürlich so die absolute Top-Performance hast du da vergleicht, es macht halt auch viel mehr drum herum.
Also wenn es dir jetzt um die letzten IO-Ops irgendwie geht, dann wahrscheinlich nicht. Und die Handhabung ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach, man muss sich schon ein paar Sachen merken.
Aber ansonsten ist ZFS, also jetzt spätestens seit Hardware-Verschlüsselung in ZFS drinne ist seit der letzten Version, ist ZFS so das Universal-Ding, was man verwenden, was man eigentlich uneingeschränkt empfehlen kann und verwenden sollte, wenn man was braucht, was einfach geht, was einfach geht, zuverlässig ist und auch unter schlechten Bedingungen funktioniert.
Damit ich immer ZFS nehme. Man kann auch ZFS ohne Probleme auf eine einzelne Festplatte machen, das ist kein Ding.
Der Patrick ist auch am Start, hoffe du hattest schöne Weihnachten. Ja, ordentlich gepressen. Eating Sounds ASMR. Was hältst du von einem Cyanology-Lass? Kann man sich kaufen. Also wenn man jetzt einfach nur was will, was geht, wenn man einfach was hinstellen will, wo, hinstellen, Netzwerk anschließen, drei Festplatten reinschieben, da hat man einfach nur was.
Dann ist ein Cyanology-Lass nicht verkehrt. Und auch von Features her kann man sich nicht beschweren. Also ein gutes Gesamtpaket ist das schon. Natürlich kriegst du es günstiger, wenn du dich selbst damit beschäftigst, selbst was bauen willst, aber das Komplettpaket kriegst du halt nicht so ohne weiteres da, selbst zusammengewurstet. Die haben ja auch viele Software, die es nur auf Cyanology-Lass gibt.
Dein Schlafrhythmus ist tot. Ja, ich hoffe du musst jetzt nicht gleich wieder arbeiten gehen.
Kann Windows Server keine Storage-Pools? Keine Ahnung.
Kenne mich mit Windows nicht aus. Zumindest nicht mit solchen advanceden Sachen. Installation complete. Restart. Bam.
Please remove. Wie ernsthaft jetzt? Ok, die CD ist doch schon raus.
Hallo? Ok, also muss man von Hand rebooten. Fängt ja schon mal gut an. Alter, ist ernsthaft.
Ist ernsthaft. Oh, nice animation hier. Ok, Forever Tools haben wir schon mal nicht standardmäßig drauf. Das ist blöd.
Warum liefern so wenige Betriebssystem-Distributoren Forever Tools standardmäßig mit aus? Verstehe ich gar nicht. Jeder probiert heutzutage das Betriebssystem erstmal in der VM aus.
Was ist das?
Dafür Epic Store Werbung gemacht? Kommt drauf an, was das Bewerben ist. Ok, das heißt wir müssen jetzt ernsthaft erstmal Forever Tools installieren oder was, damit wir das ordentlich verwenden können.
Ach, krasse. Usability wieder. Gucken wir mal, ob wir das wenigstens über den komischen Store von denen installieren können. Ok, wie macht man hier den Terminal auf? So, auch schon mal gut. VM.
Was ist das?
Es ist so was Halbherziges an VM-Wertzeug installiert. Ist aber nicht installiert. Das brauchen wir. Und da müssen wir rebooten wahrscheinlich. Weil eigentlich geht es auch ohne.
Wie sieht es bei Zorino erst mit Tablets aus? Ich habe jetzt kein Tablet hier, aber ich habe es ausprobieren können. Ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus. Ok, das erste was wir gucken müssen ist, ob es ein Dark Theme gibt. Ohne Dark Theme kann ich das nicht benutzen.
Aktuell ist FTL gratis im Epic Store. FTL ist ein Nice. Probieren wir doch mal aus, ob wir uns das hier angucken können mit Zorino OS. Gucken wir mal in den Epic Store. FTL Epic Store. Guck mal Leute, FTL, kostenlos gerade.
Endet um 17 Uhr. Morgen um 17 Uhr. Also, go, go, go. Wer es noch nicht hat. Es ist ein Nice Strategy Game.
Ok, also Knaum fühlt sich halt in der VM immer hakelig an.
Oh, die Musik.
Geil.
Guck mal hier, warum haben wir eigentlich so viele Dance Emotes?
Würdest du sagen, das selbst gebaute Nassdorfer verdammt viel Strom brauchen? Nö. Wenn du die richtige Hardware auswählst, hast du ein Gesamtpaket, was wahrscheinlich einen Tick weniger verbraucht und für das gleiche Geld mehr Performance bringt als ein Synology Nass. Dafür auch bei weitem nicht so ein schönes Gehäuse bzw. so ein schönes Gesamtpaket.
Wenn man da Wert drauf legt, wenn man beispielsweise das Synology Web Oberfläche haben will und sowas, die gibt es natürlich nicht zum Selbstinstallieren.
Ja, ich hab die ganzen Emotes schon voll.
Ok, wir gucken jetzt erstmal, wie man Themes umstellt.
Ok, man findet, wenn man Themes sucht, schon mal die richtigen Einstellungen. Das ist schon mal ein großer Pluspunkt.
Ok, Fenster kann man... Ihhh. Man kann Fenster nicht resizen mit Windows rechter Maustasse. Mit Windows mittlerer Maustasse, das ist schon mal was. Ohne das ist Müll. Ok, also, wow.
Also, was kann man hier eigentlich Themen? Black. Ahhh. Yes. Dark Theme. Der Profis hier. Das Theme der Profis.
Profis. Ja. Das ist das erste, was mir auffällt. Die Box passt nicht. Seht ihr es? Haben wir eine Bildschirmlupe? Magni Fire?
Ne. Wie sucht man unter gnome? Sucht man unter gnome überhaupt? Muss noch mal suchen. Gnome, zoom. Das muss man drücken. Super, alt, plus acht. Super, alt, plus acht. Wow.
Oh. Pargas funktioniert. Ach krasser Shit. Guckt mal. Seht ihr es? Da sieht man schon mal, dass sie nicht richtig aufgepasst haben. Super ist die Windows-Taste.
Kann man auf E3 Windows mit Maustrechtsklick ohne Borderklicken zu resizen? Jaja. Du musst deine Mod-Taste auf E3 gedrückt halten und kannst mit der rechten Maustaste resizen.
Ah. Das ist natürlich schon mal hier undenkbar. Sowas hätte es bei Steve Jobs nicht gegeben. Der hätte erstmal die Leute angeschissen und dann irgendwie in den Keller verfrachtet oder so.
Wobei das ja nichts dagegen ist. Steve Ballmer hätte erstmal ein paar Stühle nach ihnen geworfen. Da gibt es ja die Story davon. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die gelesen habt, dass der damals einen Typ, der bei Microsoft gekündigt hat und zu Google wechseln wollte, da ist er quasi hingegangen zu dem, als der Ballmer noch am Start war, ist er hingegangen zu dem Typ und hat den Stuhl nach ihm geworfen.
Also so ein rein etwas cholerischer Chef.
Stellt euch vor, Leute, ihr geht zu eurem Chef und sagt hier, Chef, ich höre in drei Monaten auf, ich reiche meine Kündigung ein, ich gehe woanders hin und das erste, was der Chef macht ist erstmal BÄM, Stuhl in die Fresse.
Da ist die Anzeige aber raus.
Ok, das mit dem Zoom funktioniert hier schon mal. Ich meine, das mit der Box triggert ein bisschen. Aber das letzte, was wir ausprobiert haben, Pop OS haben wir als letztes ausprobiert. Pop OS hat das hier nicht funktioniert.
Das war ein bisschen blöd.
Haben wir es auch probiert, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
So, wie macht man das jetzt mit dazu? Wieder Super Alt 8? Super Alt 8. Was ist denn das eigentlich für eine absolut beknackte Kombination? Das kann sich doch kein Mensch merken.
Hätte man Super Alt und Z für Zoom oder irgendwas, aber Super Alt und 8. Nein, Deep in OS habe ich aber auch auf der Liste, das probieren wir auch noch aus.
So, ok, was? Updated Software, do you want to install now? Klar. Install. Oh, Grip. Oder nicht? Ach nee, hier macht er Updates.
Gnome hat viele beknackte Kibeine gesagt, der Kerl. Ja, das ist leider wahr. Ok, wie sieht denn der Time Manager aus? Wie sieht denn das standardmäßig aus? Ah, so ist es standardmäßig.
Warum haben die nicht das Blau gelassen und haben das Blau und das Dunkel genommen? Weil dieser Blauton gefällt mir überhaupt nicht. Der andere Blauton vom Lightseam gefällt mir viel besser.
Hast du schon den Windausbruch von Kali-Linux gesehen? Nee, hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Grau war das Beste irgendwie.
Ok, das sieht ein bisschen crappy aus, ne? Shell Theme. Ist das jetzt anders?
Ah, Icons. Warum hat es eigentlich keine Icons ausgewählt? Ok, wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal so. Ist gut, ist gut.
Sondern nicht hübsch ist die Farbwahl nicht, da fand ich die... Was macht denn das eigentlich? Ah, das ist eine schöne Funktion, dass das standardmäßig eingebaut ist.
Welche Linux-Distribution könntest du empfehlen bei einem 2-in-1-Convertible wie z.B. einem Surface? Generell muss man sagen, dass Touch-Input und High DPI unter Linux so ein bisschen schwächen sind. Generell Desktop. So die klassischen Desktop-Sachen.
Kann ich dir nichts zu raten, weil ich es noch nicht ausprobiert habe. Das ist aber cool, dass sie das drin haben.
Da kann man dann sagen, hier mach mal ab... Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, hier 17.49, wenn wir jetzt mal sagen ab 18 Uhr, machen wir Dark Theme.
Das probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert, Leute. In 10 Minuten sollte es dunkel werden. Schauen wir mal. Was? Moment.
Ah, okay, das ist, dass man, wenn die Sonne aufgeht... Okay, wir probieren das mal aus. Wir lassen das mal so, mal gucken, ob es in 10 Minuten dann dunkel wird.
Icons on Desktop. Okay, was haben wir anstatt Icons on Desktop? Nichts. Home, Trash, das ist für die Windows-Leute. Network-Servers. Okay, das ist für alle Windows-Fans, dass das so ist.
Titlebar-Buttons. Ah, das ist zu minimieren, maximieren, okay. Ja, da bin ich mit rechts eigentlich ganz, ganz einverstanden. Icons, Layout.
Boah, das ist halt Windows-Style, wenn man das mag, warum nicht, ja? Es fühlt sich wirklich schnell und snappy an.
Das ist für die Mac-Fraktion hier, die freuen sich dann. Oh, hier. Ui, ui. Ah, das ist mir zu fancy, das brauch ich nicht.
Ich meine, ich bleib immer meine Manjaro mit I3, mir gehts ja nur ums Ausbilden. Ach, hier sieht man, wo was auf ist. Was jetzt? Ist jetzt gecrashed?
Hab ichs gecrashed? Tja, so. Das ist jetzt halt für die, das ist jetzt halt absolut Windows-Style, ne? Das war es mal so.
Das war es mal so. Ich glaub, damit kommt man als, ich wär ja immer gefragt so nach dem Motto, was man als Einsteiger-Distribution empfehlen konnte. Dann machen wir jetzt einfach mal Einsteiger.
Okay, okay Leute, es gibt ein Problem. Es gibt ein großes Problem. Eins Copy-Pasten geht nicht. Eins Copy-Pasten geht nicht richtig. Das Press F.
Guck mal, eins und dann will ich eins markieren und es geht nicht. Ich muss zweimal eins machen. Ah, das ist natürlich kritisch. Kritischer Hase, meine Freunde.
So, Restart. Guck mal mal, was da rauskommt, nachdem es jetzt geupdatet ist. Die wollen mich von meinen Gewohnheiten abbringen, ja kann sein, aber dafür, da würd ich mir kein neues Betriebssystem verinstalten, dass mich was von meinen Gewohnheiten abbringt.
Das soll sich eher mir anpassen, anstatt ich mich dem. Schau den Kali-Linux-Link an. Zeit mal her.
Kali-Linux tanz ich als Windows 10. Das sieht aber wirklich ähnlich aus. Guck mal, das sieht wirklich ähnlich aus.
Geht Copy-Paste von Windows, kann man klar ausprobieren. Ja, funktioniert.
Guck mal, es sieht schon verdächtig nach Windows aus gleich. Hat schon gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Da hat sich aber einer ordentlich Mühe gegeben, Gnome zu stylen.
Moin, Weizenhainz.
Okay, also bis jetzt gefällt es mir eigentlich ganz gut, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat.
Ah, Resize Nummets. So, was gibt's denn hier unten noch?
Wired Connection, Test, Restart. Ach, das ist Netzwerk hier. Was ist das? Ah, Log-Screen. Wie mach ich die Log-Screen wieder weg?
Escape, Enter. Hochwischen, ist das euer Ernst? Ich soll wischen?
Wischen auf Blastron, Alter.
Das ist ja, alles wird zum Tablet umgebaut.
Für Tablet-User ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, aber muss man unbedingt die ganzen Sachen auf Blastron immer weiter ver-tablifizieren.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es in 4 Minuten dunkel wird. Was haben wir denn noch?
Do not disturb. Jawoll, no notifications.
Select Location, okay.
Select Location, 60329. What? Ah, eine Num-Block ist standardmäßig aus, okay.
60329. Bahnhofsviertel Germany.
Wie wäre es, wenn man die Stadt mit einblendet? Ich mein, Bahnhofsviertel Germany, in welcher Stadt wohnen sie?
Bahnhofsviertel. Da fehlt Frankfurt dabei.
Nein, und in irgendeinem palästinensischen Pool wohne ich zum Glück auch nicht. Bahnhofsviertel Germany.
Wie wäre es mit Frankfurt dabei? Frankfurt? Bahnhofsviertel?
Bahnhofsviertel im Frankfurter Ghetto. Temperature unit Celsius. Ja, zum Glück ist das schon mal richtig eingestellt und nicht die Noob-Einheiten.
Okay, was passiert, wenn ich in Frankfurt suche? Ah, dann findet das, okay. Places.
Äh, was passiert bei Automatic Location?
Ein gutes Wetter braucht kein Mensch, aber wenn man jetzt hier unten guckt, dann hat man das Mini-Wetter.
Ja gut, wenn man das braucht. Ah, gut, das ist jetzt unsere Spielerei. Braucht eigentlich kein Mensch.
So, ähm, wir haben noch unsere Linux-Bewertungsmatrix vom letzten Mal. Mal angucken, was wir das letzte Mal bewertet haben.
Alles. Äh, recent. Äh. Wo ist es denn? Linux?
Linux. Hier. Also, Noob-Freundlichkeit, muss ich sagen, das war noch von Popo S. Alles, mal alles hier wegmachen.
Äh, later. Also, muss man sagen, Noob-Freundlichkeit bis jetzt ziemlich gut. Es ist alles dabei, es macht einen recht minimalistischen Eindruck.
Ähm, ich mein, was haben wir denn hier? Da ist nichts Großartiges dabei, wo man sagen könnte, ey, das ist jetzt zu überplotet, ja.
Wie viel Energie braucht man nochmal um ein britisches Pfund Wasser um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen? Eine BTU brauchst du dafür.
Das ist die Big-Brain-Einheit. Wenn ihr Leute verwirren wollt, rechnet ihr einfach in BTU.
FPS-Counter. Äh, das ist ein FPS-Counter in der VM, das sagt überhaupt nichts aus für euch jetzt. Wirklich gar nichts.
So, Software. Was kann man alles so nachinstallieren? Ok, ne, erstmal gucken, was haben wir alles standardmäßig drauf?
Accessories. Calculator. Gut, die üblichen GNOME-Basic-Geschichten. Es müsste übrigens gleich Dark Mode eingeschaltet sein.
Notepad++ kann man... Warum auch immer man unter Linux Notepad... Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das für Linux gibt.
Es gibt Notepad++ für Linux? Wirklich? Es ist 18 Uhr. Er hat kein Dark Mode eingeschaltet.
Sorry, Noes. Ach, das ist über Wine? Das ist über Wine. Wine-Anwendung aus dem App-Store. Oh, jetzt geht es aber ab hier. Jetzt wird es interessant.
So, was haben wir hier? Uhren, das hatten wir gerade auf. Braucht... Keine Ahnung, das werde ich nie aufmachen im Leben.
Äh, hallo? Warum geht das auf einmal solitär auf? Calculator, Files, Maps. Maps. Was passiert bei Maps?
Was passiert bei Maps? Ah ja. Genau da sind wir. Hat richtig reingesummt. Hier. Leute, also wenn ihr wissen wollt, wo ich wohne, hier.
Wie kann man hier suchen?
Ah ja. Frankfurt-Mine. Was auch immer. Frankfurt am Main. Jetzt ist es black.
Ha. Da ist es. Äh, das fühlt sich ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut an hier vom rein-raus-zoomen.
Also es fühlt sich ziemlich schnell an. Ich würde schon sagen, dass das... Es fühlt sich ziemlich native an. Doch, doch. Das ist sehr responsive alles.
Falsche Sprache eingestellte Sprache ist auf Englisch. So, äh, kann man da Satelliten-View machen?
Go to Current Location. Location Services. Reveal. Reveal. Es ist ja fast wie unter iOS. Location Services. Wo mache ich jetzt Location Services ein hier?
Location Services. Und du? Das ist ja wirklich mit... Die machen das... Sag mal, was ist denn das für ein Kram? Das ist ein Desktop-Betriebssystem. Warum muss ich hier so Smartphone-Geschiss machen?
Da bin ich. Exakt da, Leute. Leak. An der Autobahnausfahrt. Auffahrt? Ja. Jetzt ist es raus, Leute.
Unter einer Brücke, ja. Da sieht man mal, Leute, was passiert als Twitch-Streamer, wenn man nicht regelmäßig darauf hinweist, dass man mit Amazon Prime kostenlos subscriben kann.
Wenn man das zu selten macht, dann landet man da. Tragisch, ich weiß.
Haha, wieso? D-D-D. Fit X Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Big brain sub. Jetzt kann ich umziehen. Jetzt kann ich hier auf... in die Blume da ziehen.
So, ähm... Das ist relativ sicher. Das ganze Gnome ist Hardware Accelerated. Kann sie gar nicht dagegen werden.
Okay, kann man jetzt hier noch umschalten auf Satellitenbilder? Wie wäre es mal mit einem Hovertext für... Ah, hier. Choose map type.
Ja. Guck, da sieht man mein... da sieht man hier mein Zelt schon. Da. Von hier stream ich aus. Guck, ich hab hier so ein...
Ich hab hier so einen alten Container. Da hab ich umfunktioniert. Zum... zum Streaming-Büro. Und hier neben dran ist das Zelt, wo ich drin schlafen muss.
Ah, da sieht man mal wie gut die Satellitenbilder sind mittlerweile. Das ist Zorin OS, ja.
Ah, fühlt sich gut an. Und das ist Gnome, ja. Gnome mit dieser billigen VM-Hardware-Beschleunigung fühlt sich wirklich schnell an. Ich bin mal gespannt auf die Lite-Variante von Zorin OS.
Routenplaner. MyCrafthopper. Das ist ein Service, von dem ich im Leben noch nichts gehört hab. Okay, wie komme ich von meinem aktuellen...
Wie komme ich von meinem aktuellen Standort? Genau von da. Wie komme ich von da nach Frankfurt auf die ZEIL? Das wird mich interessieren. Nicht Zell. ZEIL.
Äh... Äh... Ach, das war zu Fuß. Mit dem Auto. Ah, äh, ja. Wie wäre das denn?
Straßennamen dabei oder so? Straßennamen? Wie blendet man da Straßennamen ein? Weil ohne Straßennamen ist ziemlich doof.
Straßennamen in der Übersicht wären schon huge praktisch. Mit was virtualisiert, das ist vor allem bei Workstations. Kann man das hier in den Settings irgendwie einstellen?
Das, das ist glaube ich... Nee, das ist Mapbox. Also OpenStreetMaps. Ja, OpenStreetMaps. Aber der Anbieter ist Mapbox, die quasi als Zwischen-AP da drin sind.
Okay, also Straßennamen kann man irgendwie nicht einblenden. Das ist ein bisschen doofes, weil Straßennamen in so einer Übersicht wären schon sehr, sehr praktisch. Gut, die komische Routenplaner-App würde ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht verwenden.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob wir Visual Studio Code installieren können. Jawoll. Version. Version. SnapStore. Auch will ich das echt als Snap installieren.
Er kommt, warum nicht? Snap ist der Sack, Alter. Ist das... Das ist Core. Das ist Core. Das ist Core. Das ist Core. Das ist Core. Das ist Core. Das ist Core.
Ich hab mir kein Ultimate gekauft. Danach probieren wir nochmal Lighthouse. Okay, install. 1,2,3,4,5,6. Huge Passwort. Aber ich muss sagen, der Eindruck ist insgesamt deutlich schöner als bei Popo S.
Was ist denn das daneben? Ah, Multiple Desktops. Wie schaltet man denn Multiple Desktops um? Shortcut. Oh nee, das war jetzt... Das war mein Windows. Geh mal fort.
Ah, Control Alt. Hoch, runter. Warum nicht Windows Alt, wenn das andere doch Windows Alt ist?
Deine Maßteilverwaltung für Visual Studios kommt doch an, was ich da drin mache. Also für mich, wenn ich irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichten mache, Plattformer ja auch, mit Abstand das Wichtigste.
Ansonsten die C, C++-Erweiterung. Alles ja irgendwie. Außerdem Qt Creator keine gescheiten C++-Idee es mal gibt. C, C, also C++, gehen wir mal fort.
Ansonsten die Markdown-Extension brauchen wir. Okay, Launch, mal gucken wie es funktioniert.
Geht, funktioniert einfach. About-Version ist sogar die aktuelle Version. Die Version ohne Santa-Hut.
Gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut. Fenster verschieben mit Windows-Tast und linker Maustaste geht, das ist gut. Fenster maximieren so geht auch, ist auch nice. Okay, installieren wir mal hier C++ installieren wir.
Gucken, ich will ja mal gucken, ob alles prinzipiell tut. Ja, doch schick.
Ich mein, dieses, dieses dunkle Blau auf dem Grau, ich weiß nicht, das ist so Geschmack sein, aber wirklich schick ist es nicht.
Git-Lens, ist Git-Lens das mit den, mit den, mit den Gatter-Einblendungen, also mit diesem hier an der linken Seite?
Ansonsten ich verwende eigentlich keinerlei Git-Geschichten im Editor oder in die IDE, ich mach das alles über Shell.
Mal genommen für Manjaro probieren, nee. Ja, das ist das, doch, das meinte ich. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch starrmäßig drauf? Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Eine To-Do-App, das ist wahrscheinlich der größte Crap überhaupt. Ja, das ist, ähm, what? Ich hab das überhaupt nicht angeklickt. Okay, jetzt wissen wir auch, was die unter professionelle Bildbearbeitung verstehen. Gimp, na gut.
Games, Eisel, Riot, Mojang, ist das Minecraft?
Mainz, Quadra-Puzzle, wir müssen gucken, das wichtigste Spiel, das wichtigste Spiel, was wir brauchen, Moment, das wichtigste Spiel, Tux-Card, super Tux-Card, das brauchen wir, ganz wichtig, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Ohne Super Tux-Card geht hier nix. Ist das nicht ein Super Mario Unterwasser Löffel? Das könnte sogar Mario Galaxy sein, äh, nicht Galaxy, Mario Odyssey sein, oder? Mario Kart, nee, Mario Kart ist es. Mario Kart ist es.
Ja, also Super Tux-Card brauchen wir auf jeden Fall. Mal gucken, ob das in der VM läuft.
Boah, super Tux-Card läuft, wie sie laut. Okay, wie stellt man die Lautstärke ein?
Okay, was? Connect? Yes, darfst du. Äh, Exit? Wie? Kann man das so mit Online-Account spielen? Nee, what? Offline-Account, ja.
Also, Story Mode. Oh Gott, nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Ist das RTX On, Leute? Wie sieht's eigentlich mit der Auflösung aus? Muss ich das jetzt im Fenster spielen?
Was ist das für ein Stumpsender?
Huge Storyline. Die Kuh ist weg, Leute. Die Kuh ist weg. Die Kuh ist weg. Was machen wir jetzt?
Oh, da kommt der Super Tux, wo der Bauch fehlt. Oh Gott, ist das schlecht. Oh, huge voice acting, Leute. Soll das ein Bowser-Abklatsch sein, oder was?
Ah, yes. Ein Augenschmaus, ein wahrer Augenschmaus. Excellent graphics. Die Gnucku ist weg, ja.
Wie macht man die Auflösung? Wie stellt man die Auflösung ein?
Auflösung. Hier, Options, Graphics. 4 zu 3, ist klar. 16 zu 9. Jawoll. Keep. Fullscreen, fullscreen.
Oh je. Hallo? Nein. Fullscreen, fullscreen geht nicht. Aber ich meine, wir können, wir können mal, ob die Auflösung...
Oh. Wahnsinn. Meine Maus geht übrigens nicht mehr, ne? Meine Maus ist, meine Maus ist kaputt.
Die Maus ist weg. Moment. Ist sie? Ne. Die Maus ist kaputt. Vielleicht muss ich das auf...
Oh. Ah, jetzt geht's. Jetzt geht die Maus wieder. Okay. Jetzt müssen wir uns huge, huge Gameplay angucken. Ja.
Boah. Ah, das geht ja mal ab hier. Open World Racing. Huge Open World Racing. Wow. Soll man da durch?
Pfeiltasten, Pfeiltasten. Mal gucken, wo die Welt zu Ende ist. Ich würd sagen, hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Das Auto hat kaum Beschleunigungsgefühl. Hier ist die Welt zu Ende, Leute. Vorbei. Die Welt...
Es ist doch alles recht statisch. Massive Graphics. Peak Open Source Gaming hier.
Gut, ich mein, man kann sich jetzt nicht so beschweren. Es ist komplett kostenlos, aber Press Fire. Leertasten. Okay.
Sieze. Wüstenmap. Oh Gott. Wir fahren gegen Gimp. Wir fahren gegen Gimp und gegen... Oh Mann. Alter, das Fahrgefühl.
Das ist ja grausig. Du kannst nur volle Pulle links, rechts. Du kannst nicht irgendwie sanft links, rechts. Das geht nicht.
Wow. Ach, das war schon das Item, oder was? Ja. Also, das ist eines der Games, was sie bewerben. Jetzt haben wir einen Klopümpel gefunden.
Noch mal. Ah, mit Lenkrad. Ah, verstehe. Oh, mit Lenkrad geht das natürlich gar nicht.
Okay, Leute. Warum hat sich das einfach in Bananen verwandelt jetzt? Nach hinten schießen geht auch nicht.
Okay, Leute. Ich will sagen. Huge Gaming Experience unterlie... Was? Eine absolut massive Gaming Experience. Super Trucks Card.
Die haben einen Trailer auf der Website, wo das Spiel gut aussieht. Können wir machen, wenn ich die Super Trucks Website...
Aber ich muss sagen, Sorin lässt sich doch intuitiv recht gut bedienen. Gefällt mir jetzt. Gefällt mir deutlich besser als PopOS.
Hast du schon mal versucht wirklich auf Linux mit Wine zu zocken? Ja, ich habe immer mal wieder ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und bin zum Schluss gekommen, dass es sich halt nicht lohnt.
Hier. Super Trucks Card 1.0 ist out. Dieses Jahr ist es erst erschienen, Leute.
Boah, so gut sah das bei mir jetzt aber nicht aus. So gut sieht das nicht aus bei... Gut, man darf nicht vergessen.
Ich habe ja auch... Ich spiele das ja auch in der VM. Also sprich, in der VM sieht es doch mal doppelscheiße aus.
So sieht das ganz gut aus. Ganz okay zumindest. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da gibt es eine Erklärung zu.
Okay, wir geben der Sache noch... Moment, Card. Eine Chance gebe ich dem Spiel noch und zwar... Card. Super. Warum findet er das nicht?
Der findet meine Games nicht. Ist es nicht da? Super Trucks Card ist weg. Da ist es. Aber im Startmenü ist es nicht.
Ausrufezeichen 1 ausgeschrieben. Ich muss jetzt gerade nochmal Graphics-Settings. Wir machen jetzt Graphics-Settings nochmal hier. Volle Pulle.
Hallo? Alter, ich will die Graphics-Settings einstellen. So, volle Pulle, Leute. Bessere Grafik geht in dem Spiel nicht. Apply.
Jawoll. Jetzt passt auf. Huge Graphics kommt jetzt. Massive Graphics. Okay, ohne Scheiß. Es sieht wirklich deutlich besser aus.
Es sieht immer noch kacke aus. Aber es sieht deutlich besser aus. Es hat Tiefenunschärfe. RTX On.
RTX On.
Es sieht deutlich besser aus.
Next-Gen. In Zukunft wird nicht mehr die Frage sein, can it run Crysis, sondern can it run Super Trucks Card.
Guck mal, hier wahnsinnig toll gehighlightene Bananen.
Hab ich überhaupt Gegner? Ich hab keine Gegner, oder?
Das sieht doch jetzt halbwegs brauchbar aus. Ich mein, es sieht nicht gut aus. Es sieht auch ziemlich kaputt aus, was die Highlights angeht, aber das liegt an meiner VM.
Das geht doch halbwegs, oder? Okay, Bäume haben keine Kollisionsabfrage. Na gut, wir machen jetzt zu. Super Trucks Card. Wichtig, dass das Game dabei ist, sonst müsste ich gar nicht, was ich hier machen soll, wenn Super Trucks Card nicht dabei wäre.
Wie sollte man RTX On machen für Super Trucks Card? Das seh ich auch so. So, was haben wir sonst noch dabei? Graphics. Document Viewer. Gimp. Na ja, wer's mag. Simple Scan. Shotwell.
Okay, absolut Standardkram. Internet. Remote Desktop Client und einen Browser. Okay, das ist sehr minimal. Office. Kalender. Ja, ja. Okay, halt ein stinknormaler Kalender.
About. Kalender. Wer hätte gedacht, dass der Kalender Kalender heißt? Ich muss sagen, das Dark Theme gefällt mir nicht so gut. Das Light Theme sieht besser aus. Diese komische Hellblaue Farbe ist nicht so schön.
Äh, gut, der Rest ist Office. Office Crap, den keiner braucht.
Nein, ich will nicht lernen, was neu ist. So, Sound und Video. Jetzt muss man die Musik wieder anmachen. Videos, Rhythm Box, Pitty, wie was auch immer das ist.
Irgendwas, was aussieht wie ein Video Editor von 1995. System Tools. Ja, ich muss sagen, für das, dass es ein Gnome 3 in der VM ist mit VM-Ware 3D, läuft das so?
System Tools. Ja, ich muss sagen, für das, dass es ein Gnome 3 in der VM ist mit VM-Ware 3D, läuft das erstaunlich gut und sieht auch gut aus.
Soren Connect. Ok, erstmal Power Statistics angucken. Ja, ah, yes, sehr viel. Oh, Wahnsinn Statistik. Soren Connect. Connect with your mobile device.
Ok, das scheint ganz... Das heißt, da kann man irgendwie... Nein, das geht bestimmt nicht mit IOS. Nee, war klar, dass das für IOS natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Searching for Devices. Ist ja keins dran. Was ist Brasero CD-Brenn-Programm?
Leute, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, es gibt nicht allzu viel zu meckern. Also, wenn jemand auf der Suche ist nach einem wirklich gut vorkonfigurierten Ubuntu mit schneller Oberfläche, was sich intuitiv bedienen lässt.
Da hat ja mit Popo erst mal eine Probleme. Oh, ganz ehrlich, wie viele Backgrounds sind dabei? Backgrounds. Sorry. Ich brauche ein Aja ja Background. Moment. Aja ja.
Mal gucken, wie einfach man Hintergrundbilder austauschen kann. Background. Ok, wie tausche ich das jetzt aus? Pictures.
Carlos? Ah, das ist ein Download, nicht Pictures. Ok. Pictures.
Woa, jetzt endlich für die ganzen Reaps unter uns. Jetzt gibt es mal was für euch hier. Ok, Hintergrund austauschen ist nicht schwierig.
Woodface. Was war Default? Das da? Ne, das war Default, ne?
Ok, das ist easy. Trash. Das ist ein ganz normaler Gnome. Nautilus. Du bist doch der größte. Ja, ich habe in meinem Leben zwei Animes geguckt oder so. Huge.
Oder ein oder zwei. Ne, auf jeden Fall nicht viel später erinnern. Das einzige Problem ist, dass Firefox nicht Darkseemed ist.
Woa, warum ist das jetzt auf einmal auf dem Desktop? Ich habe doch gar nichts gemacht. Wie kommt das auf dem Desktop?
Erstmal. Oh, so sieht der Mülleimer also voll aus. So sieht der Mülleimer voll aus und das sieht einfach aus wie ein anderes Alpen.
Na ja, gut, wenn es sein muss. So, was wollten wir noch in unserer Linux Bewertungsmatrix gucken? Optik, Look und Feel. Look und Feel ist gut.
Auch die Shortcuts und sowas. Aber Optik muss ich sagen, das Darkseem ist nicht so 100% ich meine es. Das Lightseem sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Leute, Achtung, Sonnenbrille aufsetzen. Das Lightseem sieht gut aus, aber das Darkseem ist mir irgendwie, diese komische, diese blaue Schrift, das gefällt mir nicht so gut.
Halbes Jahr, Pog. No Happy Meal for you. Danke schön. Bigbrainsub. Okay, das hier können wir uns im Prinzip sparen, weil das ist ein Ubuntu LTS. Da wird nicht allzu viel dabei sein. Gucken wir mal, was für eine Chrome Version wir bekommen können.
Chrome. Chromium. Version. Das ist die aktuelle. Auch ein Snap, okay.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was da für, ob da theoretisch GPU-Beschleunigung drin wäre. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist bestimmt normale Chrome, nicht der GPU-Beschleunigung-Chrome.
Warum Chrome, wenn du Firefox haben kannst? Weil wir ausprobieren, was alles drauf ist, weil es bestimmt genauso viele Leute gibt, die gerne Chrome verwenden.
Wie ging das About? GPU? Nee, GPU? Ah, yes. Hardware Accelerated, Video Decode Unavailable. Okay, das ist zu erwarten gewesen. Erstens, VM.
Und zweitens haben die ja mit Video Decoding unter Linux große Probleme. Mal gucken, wie YouTube läuft. Schauen wir uns mal das neueste Max-FPS-Video an. Weil da passiert nicht viel.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwas in 4K. Job Battlefield ist immer in 4K. Ah, fast. Wow, okay. Zeig ich mal. Okay, Hardtop schonmal. Wir brauchen einen ordentlichen Sachen.
Gut, das ist ganz normales Debian. Ganz gute Paket-Auswahl, ganze Sachen geht auch schnell. Terminal sieht standardmäßig okay aus. Was ist es standardmäßig für einen Terminal? Gnome-Terminal? Okay.
So, also Systemauslastung. Halt mega hoch dank keinem Hardware-Decoding. Das war anzunehmen. Ich bin auch kein Fan von Snap.
Du kannst ja von den meisten Sachen, also vor allem GoPro-Kramer kannst du natürlich immer super als Binary runterladen. Aber bei den meisten Sachen kriegst du auch noch irgendwelche Target-Sets und sowas.
Aber der offizielle App, ich nenne es mal App-Store von denen, der hat halt viele Snaps drin, so wie es aussieht.
Okay, das ist ganz normale Geschichte, so wie das unter jedem Gnome ausschaut. Was kriegen wir denn hier empfohlen?
Editors Pick in komischer Videoplayer. Notepad++. Das muss ich jetzt mal installieren. Ich verstehe zwar absolut nicht, was die Daseinsberechtigung ist, dass man standardmäßig Notepad++ im Wine angeboten kriegt.
Einfach selbst kompilieren beim Gnome, ist klar. Du brauchst erstmal 5 Stunden. Wenn es reicht, 5 Stunden, 40G Platz, 2TB RAM.
Okay, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das gut funktioniert. Ich meine im Hintergrund installiert er mir jetzt ein Wine, installiert mein Notepad++ im Wine. Mal gucken wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich meine die Daseinsberechtigung erschließt sich mir noch nicht ganz. Man muss sich mal überlegen, warum installiere ich mir einen Linux, wo es alles an Texteditoren und Geschichten gibt, was ich eigentlich nur haben will.
Warum installiere ich mir dann einen Wine mit Notepad++? Also die Daseinsberechtigung erschließt sich mir noch gar nicht so richtig.
Okay, Snap Wine wird konfiguriert. Aber eins muss man ihnen lassen, sie haben das wirklich sehr easy gemacht für Leute, die absolut keinen Plan haben. Und ich meine da soll sich ja mit richten.
Du kannst in deinem Software Center anklicken, ich hätte gerne Notepad++ und zack dann hast du Notepad++.
Was ist einfacher zu lernen? App programmieren oder Webseiten? Webseiten. Aber das schöne ist mittlerweile, wenn du Webseiten programmieren kannst, gibt es genug Geschichten, die dich quasi mit Webseiten Technologie auch App programmieren lassen. Webseiten programmieren.
Native App ist eklig. Okay, es hat eine massive Geschwindigkeit hier beim Wine konfigurieren. Ich meine es könnte daran liegen, dass ich im Hintergrund ein Battlefield Video von mir abspiele.
Da ist es. Ein Wine Notepad++. Es sieht genauso eklig aus, wie ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt habe. Aber es funktioniert.
Poggers. So und jetzt können wir es wieder zumachen, weil brauchen tun wir es nicht. Kann man filtern? Was haben die denn noch für Wine Anwendungen drauf?
Die Musik ist leicht nervig. Ah, es ist Kirby's Adventure auf dem Gameboy. Gut, damals klang das halt so.
54. Hast du das Video schon so oft abgespielt? Nein, ich habe nachgeguckt, weil es drin steht.
Bei Notepad++. Okay, habe ich nicht gesehen. Notepad nochmal aufmachen. Ja, okay. Ich finde es komisch, dass die Sachen hier im Startmenü, wir müssen mal neu starten und gucken, ob die Sachen an dem Startmenü erscheinen.
Activities, keine Ahnung. Wir können das nochmal starten, hier, Launch. Gut, ich meine, da macht das ein Wine auf. Och, geht doch. Das erste Mal hat natürlich länger gedauert, klar.
Aber die Startzeiten für die Wine Anwendungen sind okay. Was schlägt der mir sonst noch vor? Climbs. Was ist Climbs?
Ein Gnome-Fork? Warum um alles in der Welt forkt man ein Gnome? Ich könnte mir zigtausend Projekte vorstellen, die ich lieber forken würde als Gnome.
Nein, nicht Gnome. Was sage ich? Gimp. Nicht Gnome. Gimp. Ich könnte mir tausend Projekte vorstellen, die ich lieber forken würde als Gimp.
Okay, die haben das geforkt, um es umzubenennen, oder was? Das ist ja Big Brain. Ich habe nur Gnome. Ich meine Gimp, nicht Gnome.
Was ist das Problem an Gimp? Ich meine, Gimp hat den Namen doch zurecht. Warum mache ich einen Fork vom Programm, nur um es umzubekommen?
Linux beziehungsweise Open Source Community auf Einblick. Weißt du zufällig, ob man beim USG Pro 4 einen der Ladenports als dritten Uplink verwenden kann?
Nein, das habe ich noch nie verwendet. Die Unify-Firewalls und Unify-Routergeschichten habe ich noch nie verwendet. Ich habe einen Ubiquiti 10G-Switch und zwei Access Points und meinen Unify-Controller.
Das war's. Es ist in einer Sprache eine Beleidigung, deshalb kann es in Schulen nicht verwendet werden. Echt jetzt? Ja.
Just Marr, vier Monate. Pog. Aber richtig Pog. Poggers. CCTV-Viewer, irgendwie Illuminati am Start. Ich würde sagen Überwachungskamera-Viewer. Na dann nehmen wir doch lieber meinen, oder?
Also bevor wir das Ding nehmen, dann nehmen wir lieber meinen Kameraviewer. Der ist auch schöner als das Ding da. Vor allem kann er mehr.
Ja. Docker. Ja, wir gucken mal, ob Docker funktioniert. Docker hat keine guten Bewertungen. Wahrscheinlich, weil das System Docker hoffnungslos veraltet ist.
Screenshot not available. Installieren wir mal. Gucken. Surf Jelly, Kiwi, das ist irgendein peißen Ding. Keine Ahnung. Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Ich weiß nicht, ob Kiwi so eine gute verbreitete Grundlage ist für Apps.
Ne, du solltest Frontend lernen, Webseiten. Webseiten meine ich JavaScript, HTML, CSS. Weil damit kannst du dann auch ordentlich Apps bauen. Was du im Frontend verwendest ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht.
Was du im Backend verwendest ist manchmal ziemlich egal. Im Backend kannst du Django verwenden, dann kannst du Flask verwenden, dann kannst du Node verwenden, ASP, das ist egal.
Also ich würde sagen, du solltest Frontend erst mal lernen, wenn du nämlich Webseiten und Apps machen willst. Weil mit JavaScript und HTML, CSS, Frontend kommst du auch ziemlich weit, was Apps angeht.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten Leute machen wirklich noch so die richtig Hardcore-Native-Apps. Die meisten Apps sind irgendwie die verkappten Webseiten.
Okay, Lounge. Was passiert denn da, wenn ich auf Lounge klicke? Das gibt ja nichts, was ich in Grafische starten kann. Lounge. Ah, oh, der ist richtig clever. Guck mal, der macht ein Terminal auf. Macht ein Terminal auf und klemmt wieder zu.
Das ist natürlich sehr merkwürdig. Wenn ich hier starte, habe ich eben genau gesehen, es funktioniert. Aber in meinem normalen Terminal geht es nicht. Ach nee, doch hier. Nee, geht nicht. Wahrscheinlich habe ich keine Rechte für.
Das ist doof. Das ist schlecht, wenn die nicht einen standardmäßig set-upen als dockerberechtigter User. Das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Also im App-Store sind keine Web-Container mehr erlaubt. Dafür sind aber ziemlich viele Web-Technologie-Apps drin.
Also ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, wenn ich heute eine Mobile-App basteln würde, dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich mit Flutter probieren, weil mir das noch am sympathischsten aussieht.
Aber wenn ich jetzt nur Frontend zeugs könnte, dann würde ich ganz klar irgendwas in der Richtung von React Native, Nuxt, Ionic, Cordova, irgendwas in der Richtung würde ich da nehmen. Eindeutig.
Aber das heißt, wenn man generell Frontend-Gedöns gelernt hat, ist man für Apps auch schon ziemlich gut dabei. Und man hat zwei Sachen mit einem auf einen Schlag gelernt.
Die wenigsten, behaupte ich mal, werden heute wirklich mit Native-Apps in Richtung Objective-C, Swift und Java anfangen noch. Vor allem, weil die App dann auch genau auf dem einen Ding läuft.
Wenn man jetzt eine App hat, die das braucht oder so was verwenden will, warum nicht? Aber die meisten Apps sind etwas schönere Web-Seiten. Guck dir die YouTube-App an. Die YouTube-App ist im Prinzip auch nur eine schönere Web-Seite.
Und bei YouTube ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. YouTube hat noch einiges drum herum. Die Twitter-App ist im Prinzip auch nur eine schöne Web-Seite mit ein bisschen Controls drum herum für Settings.
Du bist Native-IOS-Swift-Developer. Tja. Nachher nicht, dass es dafür keinerlei Verwendung mehr gibt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten Apps heute mit Native-Sachen gebastelt werden.
Weiß nicht, ob es da eine Statistik dafür gibt. Zumindest ging es ja auch gar nicht darum, sondern es ging nur um die Frage, ob man irgendwelche Python-Frameworks für Apps lernen sollte oder Web-Seiten. Und ich bin der Meinung, eindeutig Web-Seiten.
Ich habe noch nie was Grafisches programmiert, nur Terminal-Sachen. Ist das schwierig mit X? Ja. X selber möchte man nicht programmieren. X selber ist komplett für'n Arsch.
Deswegen drücken sie sich auch so lange da vorum. Aber Wayland ist quasi die Totgeburt. Das geht auch nicht wirklich vorwärts.
Wir werden auf absehbare Zeit mit X leben müssen unter Linux. Aber glücklicherweise musst du nicht mehr X selbst programmieren.
Sondern je nachdem, was du machen möchtest und welche Sprache, gibt es verschiedene Sachen. Aber ich würde dir zwei Sachen empfehlen.
Wenn du wirklich eine richtig echte Desktop-App bauen möchtest, dann würde ich mir Qt ansehen.
Das da. Da gibt es auch eine super IDE zu. Können wir gerade mal installieren und gucken, ob die dabei ist.
Qt Creator. GTK würde ich dir wiederum nicht empfehlen. GTK mag zwar unter Linux und vor allem unter GNOME ganz nice sein.
Da gibt es sogar eine eigene Programmiersprache für.
Aber Linux ist halt nicht der Markt, wo du da jetzt wahnsinnig erfolgreiches Programm für machen könntest, so Linux Desktop Only.
Also ein bisschen Richtung Cross-Platform oder zumindest halbwegs machbaren Windows- und Mac-Support. Vor allem Windows-Support sollte man schon im Auge haben.
Okay, Qt Creator kann man so schon mal nicht installieren. Oder bin ich einfach nur zu doof, das zu finden?
Creator.
Naja, anscheinend haben sie den wirklich nicht hier in ihrem App-Store drin.
Gibt kein Qt Creator.
So, ich wollte das jetzt eigentlich zeigen. Das Ding hieß das so, oder? Ja, ist er doch. Alter, das ist ganz schön alt, oder? 452?
Wo kam das raus? 2018. Okay, das ist ganz schön alt.
Ja, ich installiere mal. Ich kann es dir trotzdem zeigen. Ist egal, ob es ein bisschen älter ist.
Erstmal halbes Internet runterladen. Qt erlaubt, glaube ich, kein Zugriff auf Low Up. Ist klar. Du kannst mit Qt alles machen. Also stinknormales CC++. Du kannst da alles mitmachen, was du willst.
Du kannst sogar X-Server-interne Sachen irgendwie tunen, wenn du willst. Also überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, was wollte ich dir gerade sagen? Genau. Also wenn du so auf die Native Desktop Schiene willst, dann auch ein bisschen Cross Platform. Dann würdest du mir Qt angucken, weil du hast ja auch explizit geschrieben, du suchst was, was mit X funktioniert. Also du willst anscheinend was unter Linux machen.
Unter Windows sieht das nochmal anders aus. Da würde ich jetzt nicht groß mit Qt rumwursten. Zumindest nicht, wenn es Native Windows sein soll. Gar vielleicht eine Windows Store App. Wie auch immer so verrückt ist, eine Windows Store App zu machen.
Und das nächste ist, das ist das, was ich dem SirOfJelly auch empfohlen habe. Wenn du grafische Anwendungen machen möchtest und dich ein bisschen mit Web-Geschichten auskennst, ich finde es ist in der heutigen Zeit nie verkehrt, ein bisschen Web-Frontend zu nennen. Man guckt mich an.
Ich bin bei weitem nicht der krasse Frontend-Held, aber trotzdem machen wir in letzter Zeit so viele JavaScript-Frontend-Geschichten, einfach weil es gut funktioniert, weil es überall läuft, weil es klappt.
Und kann man halbwegs gut JavaScript, CSS, HTML, ist es ein riesiger Vorteil für weitere, für weitere Geschichten. Erst lernt man natürlich was. Frontend, Web-Frontend-Geschichten braucht man immer. Und wenn man mal zu rüber guckt, zu sehen, wie man das macht.
Die sind auch komplett mit Web-Technologien entwickelt, außer mit ein bisschen, Discord hat noch ein bisschen C-Geschichten, C-Modules dabei.
Ich will jetzt nicht Werbung für noch mehr Elektron-Programme machen, weil ich meine, es gibt schon genug Programme, die du startest und 600 MB RAM verbrauchen, aber es ist zum Einstieg, wenn man, wenn man Richtung Cross-Platform-GUI-Programme schaut, leider, oder je nachdem, wie man es sieht, ist es ein bisschen zu spät.
Aber Web-Geschichten können, ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt. Und wenn es Native ist, dann ist es auch ein bisschen zu spät.
Das sind die besten Möglichkeiten, die man hat. Aber Web-Geschichten können, ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt. Und wenn es Native und C++ sein soll, dann würde ich ein bisschen mit Qt rumspielen.
Qt hat zwei Sachen, die haben die alten Widget-Geschichten, das ist so ein bisschen was wie Windows Forms, alt, geht, funktioniert gut, sieht aber scheiße aus.
Oder die haben das neue, die haben ihre, okay, man merkt dem Ding an, dass das ganz schön alt ist, weil du kannst auch gar keine neuen QML-Geschichten, also nicht die neuen Vorlagen auswählen. Das ist natürlich jetzt ziemlich doof.
Oh, ich hab keinen Compiler drauf, okay, lassen wir das Ganze. Ja, das ist dann auch noch eine Variante.
Discord sieht man aber auch an, dass es nicht responsive ist wie Native. Das stimmt, aber man darf nicht vergessen, was man dadurch gewinnt. Ich bin ja auch kein großer Electron-Fan. Man darf aber nicht vergessen, dass Discord dadurch einfach auf jeder Plattform verfügbar ist.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die eine Anwendung in diesem Umfang, ich weiß nicht wie groß die Teamgröße von Discord ist, aber eine Anwendung in diesem Umfang mit diesen Features bereitzustellen auf allen, inklusive Mobile, inklusive Browser, wäre nicht möglich gewesen.
Ohne, dass sie es auf Elektron-Basis gemacht hätten. Ich mein, das läuft im Browser, das läuft unter iOS, unter Android, unter Mac, unter Linux, unter Windows, das hätten die nie, die hätten niemals Native-Anwendungen mit dem Funktionsumfang gebaut und der einheitlichen Struktur, wenn sie das hätten für, ja, sagen wir mal, mindestens drei eher vier Plattformen entwickeln müssen.
Also, Elektron hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung. Ihr wisst ja, ich bin echt kein Fan von, aber für sowas wie Discord ist das toll. Zumal Discord auch noch ein Sonderfall ist. Discord ist eine Audio-Video-Anwendung. Und du willst definitiv nicht Audio-Video unter Linux mit X oder irgendwelchen komischen Frameworks machen. Das willst du nicht.
Das Schöne ist, dass im Browser Audio-Video-Bases, die sind einfach schon da und die gehen. Wie es unter Mac aussieht, weiß ich nicht. Unter Windows ist es auch nicht schön. Zumal die Audio-Video-Geschichte unten drunter einfach auf jeder Plattform komplett anders ist.
Windows ist mit ihrem Direct, früher war es Direct Show, wie heißt denn jetzt? Direct Show ist es nicht mehr. Ich sag jetzt einfach mal Direct Show. Mit ihrem Direct-Direct-X-Gedöns für Audio-Video. Linux ist Puls-Audio-Alsa bzw. X. Und im Hintergrund schwebt immer noch so ein bisschen Wayland rum.
Mac ist, wie ist das Quatsch? Coa und ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Audio-Video-Geschichten unter Audio-Kit, oder? Audio-Kit? Was auch immer.
Dann hast du nochmal iOS, was hoffentlich relativ ähnlich zu MacOS ist. Das heißt, das müsstest du wahrscheinlich nur teilweise neu machen. Coa-Audio kann sein.
Und dann kommt Android nochmal als zusätzliches System rein, was nochmal komplett anders ist. Also wenn du das Native-Fans entwickeln wollen, dann nie. Niemals. Nie im Leben. In dem Umfang und so, wie es jetzt funktioniert.
Sir of Jelly sagt, also zuerst mal HTMLC jetzt erst lernen. Also von den Optionen, die du geschrieben hast, ja. Oder direkt mit Flutter sprachen.
Ja, Moment. Das ist jetzt was, also wenn du Mobile-Apps machen möchtest, ist Flutter auf jeden Fall, wenn du jetzt quasi einsteigst, ist Flutter auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht. Flutter hat Zukunft. Flutter ist jetzt schon ziemlich beliebt.
Für Mobile-Apps ja eigentlich auch ursprünglich gemacht. Flutter geht immer mehr in Richtung, auch auf Desktop möglich. Flutter ist so ein bisschen, nicht Fuddler.
Ist auch so ein bisschen Investition in die Zukunft. Aber selbst bei Flutter ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn du ein bisschen HTMLC jetzt erst kannst. Auch wenn es anders ist in Flutter.
Aber man kann schon so ein bisschen, vor allem halt durch Dank Dart, weil Dart ist halt sehr ähnlich zu Javascript. Naja. Ich nehme es zurück. Dart hat Ähnlichkeiten mit Javascript. Sehr ähnlich zu Javascript, würde ich nicht sagen. Ist nicht verkehrt, ja.
Und Frontend zu können, so die Frontend-Basics zu können, Javascript, HTMLC, jetzt erst, ist nie falsch. Da kommst du immer mit weiter.
So und außerdem kannst du natürlich auch, wenn du sagst, ich möchte eine Mobile-Anwendung entwickeln, mit genau diesen Sachen kannst du super Mobile-Anwendungen eben basteln.
Sei es jetzt irgendwie, wie gesagt, du hast Ionic, Cordova, Electron, React Native, ein ganzes Geschiss nackst, was es nicht auch alles gibt, wo du mit Mobile-Zeug Apps basteln kannst.
Ja und es ist nicht so, als wäre Flutter nicht beliebt, ja. Meine Hoffnung im Cross-Plattform-Desktop-Bereich ruhen ja auch so ein bisschen auf Flutter.
Der Grundstein ist gelegt, es fehlen immer noch ein paar Sachen, aber da bin ich gespannt, wie es nächstes Jahr weitergeht.
Ja das ist immer Perky Agnostic, der schreibt, Discord hatte in der Vergangenheit aber schon genug Audioprobleme unter Linux. Und jetzt überlegt ihr mal, die würden was eigenes verwenden und nicht auf Chrome aufsetzen.
Was meinst du, was die dann für Probleme hätten, wenn die schon quasi als Chrome App oder als Chrome im extra Fenster Audioprobleme haben.
Kannst davon ausgehen, dass das Chrome unter Linux schon die gröbsten Sachen gelöst hat, was es da für Probleme gibt. Und wenn du da jetzt neu anfangen würdest, darum zu würsteln, ne.
Aber wie machen die das denn, zum Beispiel Video-Buffer abzugreifen? Ah!
Also, da gibt es mehrere Varianten, wie die das machen könnten. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, wie es Discord macht.
Weiß jemand, ob in Discord im Browser die Desktop-Übertragung funktioniert? Das dürfte meines Erachtens nach nicht so einfach möglich sein, weil du kannst ja im Browser-Kontext nicht auf den Desktop zugreifen.
Für höchstens halt über irgendwelche Add-ons. Funktioniert nicht? Das ist Sorin OS, das probieren wir gerade aus.
Funktioniert mit Extensions, ja, das dachte ich mir. Ja, also ich vermute mal, dass, ähm...
Discord das mit der Native Extension, also mit irgendeinem Native Node.js-Modul oder so macht.
Dass das schon in gewisser Weise betriebssystemabhängig ist, das Desktop-Sharing, was die eingebaut haben.
Warum musst du immer die 1 löschen? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1, aber ausgeschrieben.
Flutter wie Flutterschei.
Genau, Flutter wie Flutterschei. So sieht's aus. Da mag einer Ponys. Flutterschei ist eh das beste Pony.
Das ist so gelb. Wobei war Flutterschei überhaupt das Gelbe? Ja, das ist das Gelbe.
Hast du schon mal selbst Flutter probiert? Nur ganz kleines bisschen.
Ich hab mal Flutter probiert, als die ihre erste Desktop-Integration gezeigt haben vor einem Jahr.
Und das hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Allerdings gab es halt viele Controls auf dem Desktop noch nicht, die ich gerne hätte.
Anno, das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja. Ist schon gut, dass du das noch mal bestätigst, weil den Eidrohr hatte ich auch.
Ghost Rider, genau das Gefühl hab ich auch. Für Leute, die umsteigen von Windows und was haben wollen, wo sie sich zurechtfinden, macht das auf mich hier einen echt guten Eindruck.
Ich mein, ihr wisst, ich komm mit diesen ganzen fancy Oberflächen nicht klar. Ich bin mein Manjaro mit i3-WM gewöhnt, aber alles in allem, was ich hier sehe, ist das wirklich in Ordnung.
Was hat er eigentlich unter Programming? Ach da, der Cute Creator.
Ja, und ist das das andere Zeug, was ich installiert hab, auch hier drinnen?
Wir rebooten mal, Leute, und gucken, ob es dann drinnen ist.
Äh, Native Desktop Apps. Ich hab's, wie gesagt, da vor einer Weile aus, war absolut eklig und das letzte Mal, wo ich reingeguckt hab, ist noch gar nicht so lange her, ist immer noch nicht schön.
Das Problem, was ich mit Flutter und Desktop Apps hatte, dass halt ganz viele Controls gefehlt haben. Du hattest keinen ordentlichen Webview, du hattest keinerlei mögliche Kontrolle.
Es war noch ein bisschen unfertig. Alter, was geht denn jetzt ab?
Okay, es ist vorbei.
Oder nicht?
Ähm, äh, Dings, was ist das? Die Musik kommt mir echt bekannt vor. Es ist nicht Secret of Mana, es ist, was ist denn das?
Ah, genau. Fast. Ich war nah dran. Huge.
Ja, das Character Design in Chrono Trigger war von dem Dragon Ball Typ. Das erkennt man auch bei dem geplörten Bild.
Eines der besten Spiele, die je gemacht wurden.
Nein, das benutzt ganz normal Ubuntu Pakete und Snap.
Ja, das ist das, was ich hier erzählen wollte. Vor allem Make Your Computer Better oder Professional Image Editing, wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, Professional Photo Editing oder Gimp an.
Aber optisch ist es tatsächlich ganz schick. Manjaro hat mich am Nordpromet I3 gepackt. Manjaro I3 ist auch mein absolutes Lieblingskombination Linux-mäßig.
Popo S. Popo S haben wir uns letztes Mal angeguckt, das hat mir gar nicht gefallen. Flutter Web ist doch mittlerweile offiziell supportet. Ja, aber Flutter Web ist doch was anderes, oder?
Das ist die Sache für Web-Anwendungen. Ist das diese Web-Assembly-Geschichte?
Magst du, ich hätte noch eine letzte Frage, dann will ich loslegen. Muss ich jetzt für Flutter JavaScript können? Check das nicht ganz, oder kann ich da Python brauchen?
Nee, weder noch. Flutter ist eine Kombination. Flutter ist für Apps wohlgemerkt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so eine gute Sache ist.
Also wenn du noch gar keine Programmiererfahrung hast, weil die Sache ist die, wenn du Apps entwickelst, da ist immer noch ein bisschen mehr. Wie erkläre ich das am besten? Wenn du Desktop-Sachen programmierst, dann ist es relativ simpel. Kannst du auf dem Desktop ausführen, starten, debuggen und alles.
Wenn du Mobile-Sachen basteln willst, dann hast du immer noch ein bisschen Zeug drum herum. Du brauchst entweder einen Emulator, du brauchst eine Debug-Verbindung zu deinem Gerät.
Aber um zu deiner Frage zu kommen, Flutter ist eine Kombination. Flutter sind mehrere Tools. Flutter ist ein UI-Framework und Programmiersprache. Da sag ich es mal in einem. Die verwenden als Programmiersprache Dart.
Aber das ist quasi, das kommt quasi kombiniert. Flutter ist das Framework und Dart ist die Programmiersprache. Aber wenn du Flutter installierst, das ist alles in einem.
Mach mal Kirby Dream Land, kann man nachher machen. Nee, Dart alleine bringt dir nichts. Du kannst schon mit Flutter machen.
Also wenn du noch gar nichts gemacht hast, ohne Mist, ich würde dir empfehlen, fang an mit ein bisschen Frontend-Zeugs. Fang an mit HTML, JavaScript und CSS.
Und baumann paar simple Webseiten. Das JavaScript-Ökosystem ist auch total schlecht zu durchschauen, aber dein Ziel ist es ja anscheinend, du möchtest wirklich Apps programmieren.
Du möchtest Apps programmieren. Und da ist es halt nicht verschenkt, wenn du JavaScript, CSS und HTML lernst, weil es ziemlich einfach möglich ist, eben mit HTML, JavaScript und CSS auch Mobile-Anwendungen zu machen.
Flutter ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt für Apps, aber ich weiß nicht, ob Flutter die beste Wahl ist, wirklich mit ganz neu, ganz frisch, ohne Vorkenntnisse einzusteigen.
Weil für Mobile-Anwendungen gehört halt immer noch einiges drum herum.
Gimp ist gut, Pains-Champ, ja.
Und Dart ist am ehesten wie... das ist so eine Mischung. Dart ist ein bisschen so wie C-Sharp plus JavaScript, würde ich sagen.
Ja, Dart sieht ein bisschen aus wie so eine Mischung aus C-Sharp und JavaScript.
Es gibt aber einen ziemlich guten Flutter-Kurs, habe ich auf... das muss ich jetzt gerade mal gucken. Es gab auf Flutter...
...Full-Kurs. Der da. Der Kurs ist ziemlich gut. Generell sind die Videos von... der heißt übrigens auch Max, wo er so nebenbei erwähnt, sind wirklich gut.
Und das ist wirklich... oh, nice. Final Fantasy Overworld-Theme. Huge.
Das Video... mach den Kurs und dann wirst du feststellen, ob Dart und Flutter was für dich ist, was Mobile anbelangt.
Danach kannst du auch was. Das ist ein richtig guter Kurs.
Das ist ein richtig guter Kurs.
Und dann wirst du feststellen, ob Dart und Flutter was für dich ist, was Mobile anbelangt. Danach kannst du auch was. Das ist ein richtig guter Kurs.
Shutdown restart shortcuts
Ja
Schifft schifft meter key und und
E aber verwende ich nie einfach einfach streuung alt f1 reboot wenn es irgendwie hängt aber es hängt eigentlich nie
Das ASMR keks ASMR keks ich mach habe ich ja schon gesagt
Leute bei 300.000 abos mache ich ein ASMR video aber ich krieg keine 300.000 abos weil ich keine videos auf mache youtube gerade
Kizune das wünschen wir dir auch alle ja gesamte
Chat auch
Die kann man alles machen gibt es gibt tausend varianten für apps
Das stimmt homo ja das sage ich auch immer wenn man was einfaches haben will wenn man einfach nur so rudimenten
Das ist rudimentäre wenn man einfach nur sagen wir normale anwender sachen machen möchte ja immer ist gucken
youtube twitch chat chat gucken
im internet bräusen
facebook gucken
Facebook ist auch so richtig zur boomer seite verkommen
snapchat instagram
Was auch immer keine ahnung einfach nur ein browser brauche ein bisschen andere programme drumherum dann sage ich mittlerweile leute nimmt irgendwie eine ubuntu variante
nimmt mint linux und sonst was
und wenn man sich wirklich
vor hat mit linux zu beschäftigen
Dann probiert zwar mit manjaro und i3 oder sowas in der richtung oder manjaro oder artschlinux zum selbst programmieren
nicht zum selbst programmieren zum selbst einrichten ok leute
Hat mir gut gefallen hat mir besser gefallen als pop os jetzt probieren wir noch mal die minimal installation aus
Ach so ich hätte es vielleicht ausschalten sollen
Als feier emblem feier emblem war nicht so meins
Das ist secret of mana 2 ja, ok
JavaScript ist gut zum einstieg da stimmt auch wenn javascript jetzt nicht, so die
Aller konsistenteste sprache ist aber es ist auf jeden fall gut weil es gibt keine sprache
aktuell die so omnipräsent überall ist und auch immer immer mehr überall
Einzug erhält als javascript
Ja, nein das habe ich noch nicht probiert
Max kannst du eigentlich webseiten bauen beziehungsweise einen webshop erstellen also den shop habe ich noch nie selbst programmiert
wenn ich rein shop bräuchte würde ich auch mal in frage stellen ob ich dann ob ich das selbst machen würde weil da gibt es
gerade bei einem shop gibt es sehr viele sachen zu beachten
dass das auch ordentlich sicher funktioniert da würde ich irgendwas fertiges nehmen
Ok dann stecken wir mal die cd rein virtuell natürlich nur
Sorry light power up
Put from cd try your install
Jawoll
Dead left dear dead left twitch prime big prime sub huge brain
Zwei monate
Dankeschön
Warum kann ich die twitch emotes nicht sehen
Also wenn du sowas meinst wie das hier zum beispiel oder das hier dann brauchst du ffz oder better twitch tv dass du siehst
Die standard twitch emotes solltest du aber sehen
Soundtrack zu links awakening ja klar eines der drei spiele die ich für die switch habe
Znome 420 twitch prime auch hier big prime big brain sub
Was ist eigentlich deine aktuelle meinung zumindest 10 nervige aber notwendiger scheiß
Ok install was ist daran jetzt anders sieht genauso aus wie vorher
Ah es ist nix fce eindeutig es ist nix fce das vorwand gnome das ist nix fce
Das sehe ich an dem startmenü sieht aus wie xfc ist gar nix fce
Weiter detect keyboard yes yes no no french weiter
Ja next
Inserlin ist jetzt einfach mal und überschreiben das andere
Erase und install next berlin pass benutzernahme 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
Ok jetzt kann ich ein bisschen chat gucken während installiert
Meinung zu windows 10 wie gesagt ist für mich leider notwendig aber
Großer windows fan bin ich ja nun mal nicht
Also manche sachen sind halt unter windows einfach haare strömend
Zum beispiel wir haben ja letztens das ganze neu installiert
Was du für eine orgie durchnudeln musst bis du überhaupt mal auf deinem desktop bist
Dass du was machen kannst ja dann dass du dass du noch nicht mal
Ausschalten kannst du kannst nur einstellen ich will alles zu microsoft schicken oder
Wenig zum microsoft schicken du kannst gar nicht du kannst sich
Ausschalten ich will nicht zum microsoft schicken was eigentlich selbstverständlich
Mehr gibt es nicht und aber mein größter kritikpunkt an windows ist ehrlich gesagt
Dass es mittlerweile vor allem windows 10 ist da ganz extrem so unglaublich
Zusammen geschustert wirkt ich mein mal ein beispiel ja wenn man jetzt in die audio settings
Möchte wo man einstellen kann was für eine abtastrate mein audio
Meine soundkarte verwendet was wichtig ist wenn ich zum beispiel per optischen kabel
An meinem audio interface dran bin weil das habe ich glaube auf 48 kilohertz
Eingestellt und windows macht standardmäßig 44,1 kilohertz das heißt das sound klingt
Scheiße so um in dieses settings zu kommen muss ich da drauf klicken rechts da drauf
Klicken open sound settings sound control panel dann kommen die alte windows system
Steuerung irgendwie gedürnt rein digital audio advanced und da kann ich dann einstellen
Ich meine der fuck microsoft alter was ist das das findet kein mensch
Nächste sache ist wenn man beispielsweise einfach nur englische sprache haben will
Leute ich muss mal gleich was essen nehmen weil wenn man englische sprache haben will
Und deutsche tastatur bis man das findet zumal die dinge auch oftmals rumklitschen
Letztens haben wir es versucht im stream zu machen wir haben windows neu installiert
Und versucht das einzustellen du konntest es nicht öffnen da stand hier prozent eins
Drinnen anstatt options weil der button geklitscht hat
Brauchst du mal so langsam einen pxe sauber nee wozu das ist ja alles individuell vor
allem sind das distros die ich vorher nicht ausprobiert habe
Was für eine distro würdest du total computer noobs für einen alten laptop empfehlen denke
mal lubuntu oder subuntu sind nicht schlecht Was sprichst gegen wen aus 10 a 32 bt ja ich
würde sagen die soll es vielleicht mal echt mit einem mit einem ich mein sorry no s macht
keinen schlechten eindruck für noobs muss ich jetzt mal ehrlich sagen vielleicht wäre
das tatsächlich eine empfehlung wert was wir hier im stream ausprobieren ansonsten würde
ich halt sagen nehmen halt in dem mint variante mit made desktop oder sowas kann ich jetzt
nicht so wirklich ultimativ raten weil ich das problem selbst nicht habe also auf dem
auf dem laptop von meiner mutter habe ich ubuntu drauf schon ewigkeiten wollte das mal umstellen
auf elementary habe ich aber nie gemacht und mittlerweile würde ich auch nicht mal machen
ok vor immer tools sind wieder nicht dabei war aber auch zu erwarten jetzt erleben wir
mal schnell nach ach das sind die settings open vm tools desktop so dann sollte man gleich
fullscreen haben
es ist eigentlich unmöglich einen unterschied zwischen 44,1 kHz und 48, und 48 kHz ja den
unterschied zu hören ist merkst du nicht was du aber merkst ist wenn beide enden unterschiedliche
settings verwenden dann knackst nämlich wie sau weil das vom timing her überhaupt nicht
passt mein audio interface ist eingestellt das auf 48 kHz wenn ich mir noch sound settings
jetzt auf 41 auf 44,1 kHz habe knackt das wie sau die alten audio einstellung kannst
du mit m m sus cpl jetzt ernsthaft was sind das für ein stumpfsinn m m sus was cpl
alter windows die können mich mal die können mich mal sonst wo war microsoft damit das
fange ich das merke ich mir nicht aus prinzip aus trotz reaktion merke ich mir das nicht
der ande vier monate dankeschön hutsch hutsch IQs IQs ab
mx linux haben wir auch mal ausprobiert im stream hat mir von der oberfläche überhaupt
gar nicht gefallen welche er uns waren das noch mal für die twitch emotes das waren
können wir gleich mal den browser hier ausprobieren hallo firefox aufgehen das ist entweder dieses
add-on das da oder das da ich verwende das da mittlerweile ok den bayerischen tischtennis
verband wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht aufmachen das da meine ich das da ich finde
das hier schöner emotes können sie glaube ich mittlerweile von beiden beide von beiden
mgr msc für den gerät im alter def mgr.msc ne ach nee def mgmt ah greb meine güte windows
alter was ist das für ein gepiepste ah ja ja ja auf meiner das ist traurig dass man
sowas braucht schon aber gut zu wissen es wird der tag kommen wo die alten d-menüs
weg sind und so noch trash settings gibt das wird der tag kommen wo microsoft sich oma
jemand anderes suchen kann der in krab installiert zumal man hat das mit windows 8 gesehen und
dem startmenü das erste was es unter windows gab war wie ist das windows startmenü alternative
classic shell classic shell der zimt raucher twitch prime huge brain dankeschön
die wirtschaftsserie habe ich nicht angeguckt ne funktionieren twitch coins das ändert
das das ist die ganz normale twitch seite also alles was auf der twitch seite funktioniert
in ffz und und bei der twitch tv auch das ist ein add-on was einfach die normale twitch
seite modifiziert der rest bleibt gleich
wann kommen neue emotes euer muss ich mich echt drum kümmern welche linux distribution
hast du bisher bewertet oder liegt immer so viel zeit dazwischen also an popo erst kann
ich mich noch erinnern mx linux haben wir auch gemacht wir haben uns auch mal in einer
aktuellen ubuntu variante angeguckt was hatten wir noch alles ich würde mal sagen so 5 6
sachen hatten wir ist nicht so dass ich das jetzt jeden zweiten tag mache oder so
oh wie das ruckelt alter guckt euch das mal an und wie das hinterher zieht das jetzt aber
das kann man nicht verwenden dass das ist aber es ist schneller man merkt dass es schneller
ist so plötzlich ist also die sachen gehen alle deutlich schneller auf und zu okay mal
gucken mal gucken wie das mit mit einer anderen anwendung aussieht mit dem hin und her ziehen
ja let's go shopping ja oh gott es sieht alles eklig hinter hinten her man kann auch bestimmt
in xf ce 3d geschichten abstellen oder appearance hallo mein startmenü ist gecrasht leute appearance
es ist sehr verwirrend dass man hier die sachen doppelt und dreifach drinne hat ehrlich gesagt
die black warum warum gibt es das hier doppelt so in dark so in blue light so in green dark
ach das ist genau das gleiche was man hier drinne auch sondern 95 oh ja unbedingt okay
man merkt schon dass die xf ce distribution schneller ist aber das nachziehen der fenster
ist eklig kann man in xf ce nicht dieses kompo composite oder irgendwelche settings irgendwelche
craft versucht in 3d sachen einfach deaktivieren was hast du für geschenke verteilt was hast
du bekommen ist nicht so spannend dass ich jetzt groß was erzählen könnte das interessanteste
was ich verschenkt hat glaube ich war eine custom handy hülle von die mich gleich mal
gescannt haben ich habe hier eine custom handy hülle designt es ist eigentlich ganz nett
aber die haben ich gleich mal gleich mal gescannt die haben wir nämlich angeboten eine premium
geschenk box beim check out die haben sind wahrscheinlich nicht mehr drinne ne ja das
ding das hieß man noch vor ein paar tagen hieß das premium box na und wenn man sich
das so also ich mein leute 6 euro 95 6 euro 95 so wenn man sich das so anguckt denkt man
sich eigentlich dass das ist halt so nen so so so nen hard case oder irgendwie sowas
ne ich mein es sieht es sieht nicht billig aus es sieht eigentlich ganz okay aus nach
spiel ist es nette verpackung da muss ich nicht verpacken und wisst ihr was es ist es
ist ein halb verkratzter papp halb verkratze papp schachtel für 695 voll für ne asche
da ist gar maß richtig gar maß also mich okay xfc ist definitiv bei denen in der distro
nicht so aufgeräumt wie gnome ich finde ich finde finde gar nix window manager tweaks
ich glaube da müssen wir hin vermute mal wir müssen unter window manager tweaks ne ich
hab keine ahnung wo ich diese möchte gern 3d geschichte ein ausschalten kann kompositier
ah jetzt ist schnell nur dass die anderen fenster übelst rumspacken wenn man das ausschaltet
na toll ich hab jetzt die auswahl zwischen fenster die rumspacken oder anwendung die
rumspacken toll da hat mir die gnome variant als besser gefallen hat sich richtig gelohnt
die papp schachtel ja ja mx linux hat mir nicht gefallen ich muss sagen mx linux hat
sich ziemlich schnell angefühlt ja dann doch lieber windows ne ich schalte einfach auf
mit magiaro mit i3 wm um oder ist alles gut und alles schnell und alles top ok vielleicht
wir machen mal ein paar optionen aus ob es dann besser wird
ok das ist in der vm nicht benutzbar das ist in der vm nicht benutzbar das kann man
klar ausmachen sagt heute ich muss was essen ich habe übelsthunger soll ich ausmachen
oder soll ich euch ins ohr schmatzen so war zum vergleich jetzt nachdem er sehr sehr
viele des top schön gestalte des tops gesehen haben gucken wir uns jetzt mal zur abwechslung
meine standard magiaro arbeits vm an ich schmatze euch nicht so ich mute mich einfach kurz
wenn ich abheiße so so sieht mein so sieht meine standard arbeits vm aus was hatten wir
hier in windows 95 denn drinnen gibt es gar nicht mehr nix los hier top ein streamer auf
twitch du meinst auf wissenschaft und techniker das browser 95 ja oder browser ruckelt weil
ich erstmal alles laden muss wieder so jetzt geht er das ist so mein standard meine standard
arbeitsgeschichte es geht in da oben eigentlich ab das liegt dann an das liegt dann an an
wishlist studio code was zu lange offen war achso ja das ist gut ok wishlist studio code
spakt rum so und so so arbeite ich normalerweise ja also ich habe mehrere des tops die ich
durchschalten kann also eigentlich verwende ich nur 1 2 3 4 ist bei mir so ein temporärer
desktop wo ich mir irgendwas aufmache was ist ein wifi client das ist arduino das ist
arduino gedöns kann man zumachen das ist für die für meine weihnachtsbaum led steuerung
für die hier guckt und es ist so schön schnell im vergleich zu dem anderen kram das was
ich den source code den ihr da gesehen habt der ist teil von meiner weihnachtsbaum steuerung
wobei ich lasse mich einfach selbst mal zu wort kommen da muss ich das nicht nochmal
zeigen
weihnachtsbaue eher so ein busch
wohlgemerkt der weihnachtsbaum hat wlan dadurch ja wlan weihnachtsbaum
was hat die mutter dazu gesagt die fand das toll
die weibseite sieht kacke aus aber muss ja auch nicht gut aussehen
so man kann den in kerzen modus versetzen man kann den in in hell und bunt bunt macht
dann sieht das ganze dann so das ist silvester modus und der zoom ist wieder weg leute ich
kippe das mal ich kippe das mal das ist besser und jetzt kann man noch umschalten in wenn
es sich das ding fokussiert es kann man umschalten in hell dann ist einfach nur einfach nur
weiß und man kann hier unten noch mit dem plus und minus wenn man das irgendwie sehen
würde mit dem plus und minus kann man noch die helligkeit machen ich gebe mal wieder
auf kerze das ist kein weihnachtsbaum das ist ein weihnachtsbusch
ja leider hat twitter das nicht länger gecheckt informatik sagt nice geht das nächstes jahr
auf den markt ich kann den sketch höchstens irgendwo hochladen aber da ist nicht so nicht
so viel kompliziert ist dran deshalb auf reddit haben wir gesehen ja das auf reddit haben wir
gesehen wo einer snake gespielt hat
hier guckt euch an snake auf weihnachtsbaum
das ist next level mach nix hier auch dieses jahr musste es leider bei led steuerung mit
dem esp 32 bleiben hat der baum auch einen eigenen brand melder was wegen brandschutz
das braucht 0,3 watt pro led was soll da groß brennen wir können uns noch mal ein paar
github wir können uns noch ein paar github trending angucken was es da aktuell interessantes
gibt ja aber noch mal noch mal kurz die sache abzuschließen mit mit sorry no s also das
ist der vergleich zu dem wie ich halt sonst normalerweise unter linux arbeite das sieht
bei mir auf der arbeit fast ganz genauso aus ich habe ziemlich ähnliche konfig siehen
der vm wie ich auf der arbeit habe also ist nicht viel unterschied gleichen gleich desktop
anzahl gleiche desktop aufteilung ziemlich ähnliche bar ähnliche programme die drauf
sind der unterschied ist bei mir dass ich halt daheim windows habe mit einer linux vm
dank video und spielen und sonst was auf der arbeit habe ich halt komplett linux installiert
auf dem notebook hätte ja gedacht du hast so ein weihnachtsbaum ich mache das jetzt mal
auf wenn es jetzt porn ist muss ich dich bannen und das wort löschen also ich hoffe mal nicht
dass es porn ist für uns alle ist es nicht oder ist gut das gefällt mir das gefällt
mir das hat was alle sysco switcher ich weile sieht hässlich wie die nacht aus das ding
ja aber es hat irgendwie was
wer zündet als investe seine raketen auch mit einem arduino das wäre das wäre tatsächlich
excellent exquisite five hat wenn das das ist auch so ein satz den kann man nur auf
reddit nur auf twitter bringen alter nur auf twitch bringen oder excellent five hat das
das checkt das ist doch so das kapiert auch weltweit niemand außer die leute die twitch
gucken moin kann mir jemand einen router sorry sysco leute router für ein 50k vdsl telekom
leitung empfehlen ein analoges telefon muss noch dran weiß was kauft ihr einfach eine
fritzbox es gibt glaube ich nix was so easy einzurichten ist und einfach funktioniert
vor allem an einem telekom anschluss wie eine fritzbox das sage ich als sehr technikaffiner
mensch ja aber hol dir einfach eine fritzbox was für ein arbeitsnordburg hast du das ist
irgendein lenovo party fragt keine ahnung weiß ich nicht
warum ist die musik aus
das sind singpartie ja ich weiß aber nicht welche t450 t480 kann schon sein ja es hat
auf jeden fall vier kerne vier kerne die meiner meinung ein bisschen langsam sind dafür
als ordentlich ramone ssd du kannst dich sogar mit einer fritzbox per ssh verbinden als wäre
jetzt ssh verbindung irgendwas tolles ich kann mich sogar auf meinen staubsauger mit
ssh verbinden und es ist kein witz alle die öfters den stream gucken wissen dass es stimmt
staubsauger ssh ist das beste dann seit 2019 im iot zeitalter angekommen wenn der psh auf
auch staubsauger könnte die steckdosenleiste hat kein ssh die steckdosenleiste hat leider
leider kein ssh aber die steckdosenleiste hat ein webinterface ist doch auch schon mal
was oder wenn die steckdosenleiste hat kein ssh aber die steckdosenleiste hat ein webinterface
aber natürlich nur mit custom firmware drauf ip liegt auf fuck oh nein kannst du auch mit
deine toilette machen meine toilette ist leider ein bisschen alt die hat irgend so eine nicht
dokumentierte nicht genormte herstellerschnittstelle nur wo ich keine ahnung habe wo ich da was
abgreifen kann also hier der da der da
ne das ist keine serielle schrittstelle also der klo hat leider nur hier neben gibt es
ja irgendein bild wo man das sieht der hat hier neben so eine schrittstelle auf der anderen
seite das ist die seite das ist die seite wo man mit den settings also das ist die seite
wo man wasser anmachen kann belüftung anmachen kann fön anmachen kann und alle wasserwärme
ganz geschiss aber auf der anderen seite ist hier ist die fernbedienung dazu auf der
anderen seite hat das ding in irgendeine stützstelle vom hersteller und ein kane das kostet noch
eine ganze ecke mehr aber man sieht sie leider nicht zumindest ist es leider zu alt ich kann
davon nichts gescheit abgreifen aber big brain war am werk und zwar ich habe mir überlegt
ob man an die buttons gibt es das hier vielleicht mal in etwas höhere auflösung dass ich
auch was kurz zu zeigen kann gut hier neben hat das ding nämlich zwei leds der led für
bestörung und led für abluft ist an ich wollte da ein esp 866 dran machen mit so einem photoresistor
der quasi kontrolliert ob einer der leds an ist und wenn einer der leds an ist weiß
ich entweder das ist die lüftungs led das heißt es sitzt jemand auf dem klo oder es
ist die fehler led dann hat das klo irgendwie ein fehler und braucht neues äh ähm dings
reinigungsmittel oder oder den neuen filter danach gefiltert werden muss habe ich überlegt
man kann bestimmt das hier unten ab machen das heißt ich könnte im prinzip da irgendwie
den esp controller reinlegen und hier neben mache ich dann halt die paar kabel hoch für
die leds hat max kein content mehr oder warum redet übers klo ja kann man so und so sehen
ja ich habe noch so viel content aber der klo ist jetzt wichtiger manch einer würde
vielleicht jetzt sagen scheiß content ich will nicht was in meinen klo legen ich will
was unter die abdeckung von meinem klo legen die frage ist warum er so ein klo hat weil
das richtig geil ist leute das ist richtig geil das ist die beste investition die ich
getätigt habe mit meiner kohle die letzten 15 jahre dieses klo zu holen das ist nicht
unbequem das ist einfach nur relativ groß die die die klo schüssel ist exakt eine ganz
normale klo schüssel wie man das kennt also überhaupt kein unterschied nur dass die
beschichtung richtig gut ist das heißt es bleibt keine kacke hängen weil weil high
iq beschichtung und man kann sich den hinteren abspülen lassen was sehr angenehm ist den
fön verwende ich nicht hat das sitzheizung nähe es hat keine sitzheizung aber es hat
eine wasserheizung also sprich man kriegt nicht mit kaltem wasser den hinteren abgespült
da habe ich also rotnet da habe ich mir jetzt noch nicht im detail so die gedanken zu gemacht
vor allem weiß ich nicht ob das das richtige thema für den twitch chat ist endlich ein
neues emote nullw neue emote ich habe mittlerweile soll ich mal gucken wie viele emote slots
ich schon habe dass ich weiß wie viele emote sich mal über fiver bestellen müsste oh das
dashboard sieht anders aus fack ach du kacke oje wo sieht man das
ok leute ich habe keine ahnung wo man das einstellt mehr partner hier emotes ok ich
habe jetzt vier emotes drinne und ich habe insgesamt eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
sieben acht neun zehn elf zwölf dreizehn vierzehn fünfzehn sechzehn siebzehn achtzehn
plus zwei tier 1 tier 2 20 emote slots und ich habe vier emotes drinne ok das ist echt
fail max das ist echt fail das ist echt fail ich muss mal wirklich die muss man wirklich
paar fiverr jungs beauftragen und medels fiverr und fiverrinnen beauftragen ein paar neue
emotes zu machen das geht ja nicht an dass wir 20 emote slots haben und ich habe hier
irgendwie nur 4 emote aber dafür sind es nice emotes ne kann man nix sagen emotes sind
schon big brain die wir drinne haben also also wupps ist ja mein persönlich persönliches
lieblings emote und wuppold wuppold ist auch ein wupps finde ich gut das sind keine bella
twitch tv emotes wupps ist hand gefertigt von jemand hier aus dem stream ich weiß nicht
ich glaube das series max war es oder hand gefertigt hier aus dem stream wupp großes s ok also
was trendet denn auf github das haben wir schon eine weile nicht mehr geguckt was trendet
aber leute ich habe hunger ich muss was essen drei stunden alter wie lang war ich heute
heute morgen zweieinhalb stunden jetzt drei stunden hört ja gar nicht mehr auf da gehen
die streams hier schlag auf schlag ok ich esse mal nebenbei was ne also ich mute mich
mal ab und zu mal wir machen jetzt keine asmr eating sounds
oje was seh ich da es gibt ein frontend framework von tencent
das hat die china spyware schon drinne beziehungsweise der call of duty mobile shop
tencent hippie cross platform framework design for web developer moment es ist c++ alter was
ok introduction video ah yes moment wir kommen es ist introduction video kutter
excellent framework
Stonks
Hippie, ich hab's verstanden, ein Wort wenigstens
Was die schreiben, Source code auf chinesisch, echt. Wo war das? Hier? Moment, Moment
Also das könnte man, wollte ich rotnet, ja, das könnte echt mal neues Lieblingsframework werden
Aber das ist sowas von chinesisch. Wo hat man es denn gesehen mit die Coden auf chinesisch?
Hippie Kuckoo, Hippie Kuckoo
Ja, Const Deep Link, ne ne ne ne, das ist, das ist englisch
Da
7000, ne, das ist, das ist nicht chinesisch
Hier, Const Deep Link, Item, Scan
If pick is installed
Was machen wir, was können die Schweine da für denn jetzt?
STBA 42, Big Prime Sub, huge
Dankeschön
Cool, encode
Das C++, ja das ist C++
Andi Tech Gear Stufe 1, Dankeschön, nice. Big Brain, high IQ Sub
Das ist das Bye Bye Code, immer diese Vorurteile hier Leute
Upload Append
Programming Grill
Hippie
Die Sound Lippen Synchro ist nicht so ganz
Er hat gerade gesagt, Hippie ist jetzt auch on GitHub
Ihr könnt es ja mal ausprobieren
Was hat er gerade gesagt?
Ja, das ist Hippie
Across Platform Framework Design for Web Developer, okay es ist, ich habe nicht so genau was es gecheckt, was es ist
Ist es ein C++ Web Framework oder
Ist es ein Cross Platform App Framework in C++ was sich an Web Developer richtet?
Examples
Oh, oh, Hippie View Demo
Ok, es ist JavaScript
Hippie Demo Xcode
Punkt M, was ist denn Punkt M, bitteschön für eine Sprache
Objective C, oder was ist denn Punkt M, ist es Objective C?
Module, das wollte ich gar nicht abspielen, wie sind wir jetzt auf das Flutter Tutorial gekommen?
Das M ist für Mehrwert
Ah, Chat
Das ist irgendein IOS Sample
Ok, es ist anscheinend ein App Framework
Was sich an Web, ein C++ App Framework, was sich allerdings an Web Entwickler richtet
Also im Prinzip ein bisschen so was wie Ionic oder sowas
Oh, Andy Teschkeer, Dankeschön, er hat Plutonia, was, Plutonarn, ein Stufe 1 Abo geschenkt, Dankeschön
Big Brain, Big Gift
Vergiss das Prime, Dankeschön, nice
Ich hab mein Brötchen zur Hälfte runter geschmissen, wartet mal
So, ok, ob man noch ein weiteres Cross-Plattformen, JavaScript, Java, cool, vielleicht, vielleicht hat es hier irgendwelche Vorteile
Ich kann es euch leider nicht sagen, weil, ok, ok, das komplett in Englisch
Das ist so was wie Ionic oder Cordova, oder sowas in der Richtung
Flex-Layout-Engine
Es ist, wisst ihr was ein bisschen doof ist an IOS-Apps, man braucht das man zwingend einen Apple-Account und Xcode braucht um überhaupt irgendwelche Apps zu machen
Ich mein, warum brauch ich einen Mac um IOS-Anwendungen zu kompilieren oder zu machen
Ok, was trendet denn sonst noch so?
Wir gucken uns mal wieder an, Trending heute und Trending this week
Ok, auf dem ersten Platz trendet irgendwie Advanced Java in Chinesisch
Das sind zwei Sachen, die mir nicht liegen, sowohl Chinesisch, als auch Java, deswegen überspringe ich das mal
Was ein edler Chat, das ist bester Chat hier
Tester-Sunshine, 123, das kenn ich noch
Leute, wisst ihr noch was das war? Ich hab's mir gemerkt
Ich weiß noch, was das war, 123.06, wisst ihr es auch noch?
Das war die Chinesische Bahn
Genau, Quai
Chinesische Bahn-App
Ok, was auch immer, irgendein Buch
Das zeig ich schon mal her
6-Rom-Arts-Sterne, Hä, ist es jetzt Self-Horstel oder nicht, aber man kann es selbst, Self-Horstel
Ok, wahrscheinlich ist das für Leute, die auch wollen, dass ihre Dokumentation gelesen wird, weil alle die wollen, dass es nicht gelesen wird, schreiben es einfach in Confluence rein
Und sobald es in Confluence drinnen ist, guckt nie wieder irgendeine Seele da rein
Ich kann das schon abbrechen, wenn ich will, aber das ist komplett schon in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen
Also die Chinesische Bahn hat auf jeden Fall beliebtere Apps als die Deutsche Bahn, so finde ich schon mal sicher
Aber wahrscheinlich kommt die Chinesische Bahn auch pünktlicher als die Deutsche Bahn
Sag mal, wie viele Chinesische Repos trenden, ist das krass
Guck dir das mal an, Alp Github ist voller Chinesische Repos, die trenden
Spring plus Spring MVC klingt auch sehr nach Java
Modrix, habe ich noch nie was von gehört, Download Manager, weiß gar nicht, dass man sowas noch verwendet
Ah, Chinesisch, Leute das ist bestimmt Elektron, das ist safe in der Elektron Anwendung, ich sag's euch
Das ist safe in der Elektron Anwendung, ja, IGIT
Oben stand ein Elektron, hab ich nicht gesehen
Mr. OP, ja so hätte ich das ja auch gerne
Modrix, so wie Matrix nur mit O
Irgendwelche Bücher, auf jeden Fall auch wieder was in Chinesisch, aber Thumbs Up Leute, Thumbs Up
Daumen hoch
Ah, yes, Exzellent, exquisite Text
Gibt's bei dir eigentlich auch Kontakt zum Friseur, klar, Friseur kannte ich ja auch schon, bevor ihr ganze YouTube Zeug gemacht habt
Dark Table, hab ich noch nie was von gehört, was ist das, Fotogramm, hä
Oder
Photography Workflow Application and Raw Developer
Ok, wenn man die Projektbeschreibung liest, aber kein Plattenschimmer hat, was es ist
Ja, ok, mach keine Fotos
So wie Lightroom plus Dark
Awesome Design Tools, best Design Tools, boah
Von Lisa Ciuba, das ist Lisa
Best Design Tools and Plugins for everything
Ok, ist recht umfangreich
Ich glaube, das kann man sich tatsächlich mal speichern
Was immer da so alles drin ist
Screenshot Tools
Warum nicht
Aber es scheint so klar, man nennt das Awesome und schon im Training
Diese Awesome Lists
Ist ja angesagt, wusstet ihr, dass es eine Awesome List of Awesome Lists gibt
Das ist Next Level
Unter Darkroom verstehen aber viele was anderes
Ja, schon
Allerdings die meisten Leute, die was mit Fotos machen, wahrscheinlich nicht
Das wäre doch was für Surf Jelly vorhin gewesen
Spring Boot plus View
In China ist Java anscheinend voll angesagt
Von den Training Repos sind die Hälfte Chinesisch und die Hälfte davon ist Java
Was
Was hab ich da vor mir Leute
Ich hab ne Bildumgebung für Programme vor mir, die ich auf nem F1C100 laufen lassen kann und davon kann ich mir da ne Visitenkarte bauen oder was
Wenn du die Wahl zwischen Avira Free und Windows Defender hättest, was würdest du dazu nehmen und warum Windows Defender
Einfach weil es dabei ist und mir nicht noch zusätzlichen Crap installiert
Ich versteh hiervon nicht den Sinn, aber es ist nice
Developer Roadmap
Ok, paar Buzzwords
Solid, Kiss, Yagny
Solid sagt mir was, Kiss sagt mir was
Was zur Hölle ist Yagny
Yagny
Du wirst es nicht brauchen
Die Visitenkarte hat was, ja finde ich auch
Warum sind Virenprogramme unnötig, weil der Windows Defender eigentlich alles das macht was andere Virenprogramme auch machen ohne den ganzen anderen Crap dabei zu haben
Was lernt man sonst noch, Git, ja gut damit verdien ich mein Geld
Basic Terminal Usage, Data Structures, Algorithms
Krieg ich alles gebacken, Yagny sagt mir gar nichts, aber Solid und Furchtbar
Ich kann euch nicht aus dem Kopf sagen für was die einzelnen Buchstaben mit Solid stehen
Single Responsibility, frag mich nicht, keine Ahnung
Zu viel Theorie, ich programmier lieber als Theorie zu craften
Semantic Versioning, SSH, HTTPS, Design Patterns, Character Encoding
Vor allem da muss man sich leider immer noch 2019 Gedanken machen
Verfolgst du den Chaos Communication Conquest, ne ich guck mir wieder die Caste, also die Wots an wenn es fertig ist
Was wir uns unbedingt angucken müssen ist Bahn Mining
Es hängt irgendwie ein bisschen gerade der Browser
Das muss man uns angucken wenn es raus ist
Ich muss mal kurz den Browser nachsteuern, irgendwie hängt er, irgendwie spackt er mega rum
Weiß nicht so genau warum, aber er spackt rum
Jetzt geht's, wann ist denn der Vortrag über, wann ist denn der Vortrag, der müsste doch jetzt irgendwie sein
Das ist doch jetzt irgendwann, da ist es doch hier, Bahn Mining
Ist das der Nachfolge von Spiegel Mining, ja das ist der Typ mit der Xerox Druckergeschichte und Spiegel Mining
Das gucken wir uns an, was spackt das denn jetzt hier gerade so rum
Wisst ihr was, Windows Style, wir rebooten einfach wenn es nicht funktioniert
Eats, einfach rebooten immer
Hier ein paar Tabs zu machen
Also an welchem, das läuft doch jetzt gerade irgendwo oder, ist es nicht gerade jetzt am laufen
Ach nee 28.12. also übermorgen
Das Wort davon gucken wir uns dann auf jeden Fall an
Zornen schon durch, ja seit 20 Minuten oder so
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch kurz die aktuellen GitHub Trends an, während ich am futtern bin
Noch mal chinesische Repos
Was macht das
Ah, der guckt ob das irgendwie anfällig ist gegen irgendwelche bekannten Sicherheitslücken oder so
Sieht doch ganz cool aus, oder brauchbar je nachdem für was
Was läuft denn gerade
Radius Gaiden, Snowfield, irgend so ein Baller Ding aus sieht aus wie aus Super Nintendo Zeiten
Wie nicht die Musik, was dann
Ach so das Repo, das ist hier X-Ray, keine Ahnung
Irgend ein chinesisches Hacking oder Security Tool, das aktuelle Thema, wir gucken uns die aktuellen GitHub Trends an
Und nebenbei futter ich was
Beste
Das ist wenn man keinen Bock auf Arduino und C++ hat, dann macht man das hier mit dem offiziellen ESP Framework
Homemade Machine Learning
Incubator Hoodie
Federsack
Hört sich an wie ein Staubsauger oder
Mein Federsack
War jetzt nicht so viel spannendes dabei
Unglaublich viele chinesische Repos
Okay was ist die Woche getrendet
China Bahn, also die China Bahn braucht echt viele Apps
Oh Gott jetzt gehts los Leute, jetzt ist vorbei
Jetzt können wir nur nicht mehr den Source Code lesen aus China
Jetzt wird der Source Code auch noch in Chinesisch geschrieben
Wen-Yan-Lang
What
Ach das ist irgendeine esoterische Programmiersprache
Sowas wie Brainfuck nur für
Oder LOL Code was wir letztens hatten
Nur für Chinesisch
What
Das ist Next Level Leute
Da hört es jetzt auf
Spring Boot Demo
So eins muss man echt sagen
Chinesische Repos
Ganz stark im Kommen und die Chinesen verwenden unglaublich gerne Java
Wie es aussieht
Ich verstehs zwar nicht
Aber Java ist da voll angesagt
Ja White Space hab ich schon mal was zugelesen
Chinesische Dichter sind auch auf GitHub eingetroffen
Machine Learning from scratch
Na gut also Pyson Repo natürlich ist richtig
Mia Ocha
Auch Java
Die ganzen China Repos sind in Java
Habt ihr eine Ahnung das sind QR Reader oder so
Habt ihr eine Ahnung warum die Chinesischen Repos alle in Java sind
Java oder die Chinesische Bahn die ist in Pyson
Sie scharfen weniger warum mögen die Oracle mehr als Microsoft
Das muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären
Microsoft ist böse
Ja Oracle ist viel besser oder wie
Ah yes
Ah das ist irgendein China Java Skript Kongress
Lead Code Animation
Zum Teufel ist Lead Code ist das ist das Chinesische Stack Overflow
Das ist das Chinesische Stack Overflow
Ne das ist das Chinesische Udemy oder sowas
Ne doch nicht das ist das
Das ist das Chinesische Stack Overflow oder sowas in der Richtung
Ok die Seite ist huge schnell
Es ist weder noch ne es ist eine Übungs Plattform
Ne Chinesische irgendwie oder ist doch nicht mal Chinesisch
Ist ist das ist so Coding Challenge Geschichten
Ok
Da könnten wir auch ein paar Sachen machen
Challenge Doom EMAX
Ich hab schon gedacht die spielen Doom in EMAX
Aber es ist einfach nur ne EMAX Konfig die Doom heißt
Ich hab schon gedacht sie haben es geschafft in EMAX Doom zu spielen
Es würde mich nicht wundern wenn man in EMAX Doom spielen kann ehrlich gesagt
Doom EMAX
Also E-Lisp ist wirklich ne Sache die muss man hassen
Moin Mystic Good Job
WeChat Extent ok das ist China China Prolab
Ok das ist irgendwelche Durchsuchmaschinen
Seata
Was High Performance Open Source Distributed Transaction Solution
Das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon wusste nicht was es ist
Da ist die Matrix mit O das hatten wir auch schon
Go Micro
Go Micro Services Development Framework
Was braucht man da für ne extra Framework für
Was macht es
Irgendwie viel Magic im Hintergrund
Der Aspekt bei Micro Services liegt eigentlich auf dem Micro
Wo man eigentlich davon ausgehen müsste die sind so
Schön runtergebrochen isoliert die Services dass man da keine Special Framework für braucht
Aber anscheinend habe ich mich getäuscht ich weiß nicht ich checke auch nicht was es macht
Ach das ist ah jetzt verstehe ich es
Das ist ein Framework dass es einfacher ist dass dann die unterschiedlichen Micro Services
Miteinander ordentlich kommunizieren können
Ich denke mir ja manchmal so
So weil es der aktuelle Trend ist aber ich denke mir immer so wenn man dann 50
Micro Services gebaut hat und daraus wieder quasi ne Anwendung stricken muss wie die
Zusammenarbeiten vielleicht hätte man gleich ne komplette Anwendung machen sollen
Anstatt 50 Micro Services die zusammengehören
Ah weiß nicht vielleicht bin ich da zu Old School für
Ja STBA so sieht es aus
Ist bei uns auf der Arbeit auch krass äh
Wo sie jetzt angefangen haben
Es ist eigentlich so beknackt
Sie haben jetzt erzählte nachdem alles in die Cloud alles in die Cloud und was macht
man jetzt die Server die halt total einfach umzuziehen sind packt man in die Cloud aber
nicht etwa indem man die Anwendung so entwickelt dass sie gut in Azure laufen könnte nee nee
man macht einfach eine VM in Azure und sagt dann wir sind in der Cloud also wird es den
Unterschied machen ob man die VM auf dem alten ESX Cluster laufen lässt oder in der Azure
Cloud
Ah ja gut so ist das aber halt wenn Entscheidungen nicht aus technischer Sicht sondern aus BWL
Management Sicht äh getroffen werden
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen eigentlich ist mir das auch ziemlich egal
Ja BassiW theoretisch ist das ist das so da hast du natürlich Recht
Es kommt aber ganz entscheidend drauf an wie es gebaut wird ich kann auch einen in Anführungsstil
nehmen wir mal Microservice so bauen dass ich da quasi so Hard Dependencies drauf habe
mit meinen anderen Microservices
Wir haben nicht mal Kubernetes
Es ist auch gar nicht mal so schlecht wenn man nicht jeden Scheiß mitmachen muss
Bei uns macht Kubernetes mehr Probleme als ähm so die klassische Virtualisierungsinfrastruktur
gemacht hat
Mehr Probleme und vor allem anders gelagerter Probleme wo man auch nicht direkt weiß was
Sache ist
Weil Kubernetes ist schon etwas kryptisch an manchen Stellen
Libra
Ist das eine Kryptowährung in Rust
Das hat ja auch in Rust gefehlt eine Kryptowährung
Aber ne das ist die ist das nicht dieses Facebook Ding
Ist das nicht dieses Facebook oder verwechsel ich das jetzt
Ne das ist was anderes oder
Warum taucht da Facebook nicht auf
Denken sie das ist keine gute Werbung wenn da Facebook auftaucht
Facebook taucht hier überhaupt nicht auf drinne
Proxy Pool auf Chinesisch alles klar
Ist ein Lautpalänzer oder
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den Epic Sax Guy
Alibaba Druid
Wisst ihr wenn man selbst nicht nach China geht wenn einem das zu weit ist dann lässt
man einfach in China zu sich kommen mit Aliexpress
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut jetzt
Was machst du wir gucken uns GitHub Trends an
Alibaba Druid was ist das
Was ist das
Wieso so viel China Kram
Weil GitHub gerade mit Trending Repos voll ist mit China Kram
Alibaba Druid ist eine der besten Database Konnektionspools
Gnolerix sagt ihr GitHub was GitHub ist eine Webseite wo Leute ihren Source Code
drauf hosten und die Trending Repos sind die die aktuell besonders viele Sterne kriegen
Also die besonders beliebten die besonders beliebten Gruppen quasi an Projekten
Wenn man sich GitHub Trends anguckt dann weiß man was aktuell angesagt ist
Und was wir festgestellt haben ist dass so viele chinesischen Repos angesagt sind
Ist Java nicht veraltet in China nein ist es nicht und in China ist recht nicht
Da ist ja alles ok Leute ich habe keine Ahnung was es ist es ist es ist ein ein es ist die
der beste Database Konnektionspool
Ich dachte eine Konnektionspool ist nicht was ausgelagertes sondern
Ich finde was im Application Server oder was auf Datenbankseite
Geh mal auf die Benchmarks wo sind denn die
Bench ah hier Benchmarks
Tomcat JDBC das ist so das Standard Ding
Leute wie wäre es mit Einheiten dahinter schreiben was was für was bedeutet die Zahl
überhaupt
Radwürfel
Konnektions sind das Konnektions
Anzahl der Thread sind hier oben
Ich glaube das sind Konnektions pro Thread oder irgendwie sowas
Nee weniger ist besser
Also man braucht weniger Konnektions um das gleiche zu machen
Irgendwie so Leute kein Schimmer
Millisekunden
Das wäre verdammt lang
311 Millisekunden für eine Datenbank Antwort
Geschweige denn 32 Sekunden Alter
32 Sekunden kannst du erstmal Kaffee machen bevor die Webseite aufgeht
Kannst du erstmal den hier machen bevor die Webseite geladen ist mit 32 Sekunden zur
Datenbank
Oh das ist gut hier
Das ist gut
Das ist ein Gui, ein Vector mal Library für C++
Da kann man Spiele, Gaming Interfaces und so mit machen
Für normale Anwendungen jetzt verwendet man es eher nicht
Aber ist nice
Also Striker, ich glaube das ist was anderes
Aber sicher bin ich mir da nicht
Einige Cheat Provider nutzen das
Ja bietet sich an
Das ist halt quasi so ein In-Process
Wie nennt man das?
Immediate Mode
Genau also musst du quasi jedes Mal alles neu malen
Das ist halt schön klein und man kann halt schön damit einfach ein bisschen Gui malen
Das wundert mich nicht, dass es einige Cheat Anbieter benutzen
Wir hätten aber auch genauso viele JIT Anwendungen um damit irgendwelche Overlays zu malen
Guck mal sogar Microsoft hat ein extra Repo für Chinese Students
AI Education
Magnet-W-App ist das so aus wie MonkaW
Magnet-W MonkaW
Das ist ein Kalender
Ich checke nämlich nicht so genau was es ist
Eine Notiz-Block, eine Link-in-Link-in-Link-Manager
Was könnte das sein Leute?
Ein Download-Manager?
Ein Torrent Client
Das ist ein Torrent Client
Das ist ein Torrent Client, jetzt schenke ich das
Den Torrenten machen wir garantiert nicht auf
Okay also Leute, die Trending-Repos des Tages und der Woche waren jetzt ein bisschen enttäuschend
Gucken was können wir noch mal schnell drüber
China-Repo, China-Repo, China-Repo, Halo
Der Master-Chief
Ahja, eindeutig, da ist er
Platte
Was ist denn das Beste, das kann man nicht sehen, das muss man über externe Seiten
machen
Wir haben uns das letzte Mal meist bewertet, wie hieß das denn, GitHub Stars oder so
Most Stars, wie hieß denn das, wir haben uns das letztens sowas gefunden und wir haben
uns das letztens schonmal angeguckt
Get Most Wanted, nee das war das nicht
Get Star Ranking, genau, ah das war das
So und kann man uns jetzt aufs Jahr über, nee das ist nur insgesamt, man kann das nicht
aufs Jahr über einstellen
Gibt meines Wissens nach nichts, wo man gucken kann, was ist das beliebteste Repo des Jahres
Nee, das wird zu risikoreich
Was haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon angeguckt
GitHub Most Stars 2019, wir bräuchten sowas wie Socialblade für GitHub
Javascript Repos, Igit hör auf
Die haben es verdient, die haben es wirklich verdient
Oder ist es schon der aktuelle
Aber da haben die keine Repos drin, das haben wir uns doch schonmal angeguckt, da hatten
sie doch keine Repos drin
Top Entrending Projects hier
Top Open Source Projects
Alter die Musik, was ist das
Aja ja
Wie ist Code, ja das wundert mich nicht, aber wo sind da die Sachen nur für dieses
Jahr
Das geht ab, aber gut die haben auch glaube ich umbenannt, die haben das glaube ich auch
neu aufgemacht
Was ist Helmcharts, aah, Syplus ist frontend testing Javascript
Naja Homeworld, so ganz isoliert bin ich nicht, man kann immer noch bei mir aufs Netzwerk
zugreifen
Die vor allem hat ja Netzwerk Zugriff, muss ich die Netzwerk Zugriff wegnehmen, aber dann
könnte ich ja mein Internet
Ja natten, aber trotzdem, wenn ich natte dann komme ich ja trotzdem immer mal Netzwerk
anbieten, aber es geht auch nicht
Naja ok, skippen wir mal kurz drüber
Was ist denn hier los, das ist ja alles in Chinesisch dieses Mal
Cross Platform Gui, oh, oh das müssen wir uns mal angucken
Cross Platform Gui ist ja so mein geheimes Hobby, Cross Platform Gui muss ich mir alles
angucken was Cross Platform Gui ist
Es sieht ein bisschen nach Javascript aus oder, you Jim, 6 Monate, Dankeschön, huge,
big brain
Haben wir mal nen, haben wir mal nen Beispiel, haben wir mal nen Example, Example, Hello
World, wir brauchen ne, Tempoke Dex, wir brauchen, wir brauchen nen Hello World Example
Rust kann schon hässlich sein ja
Also Rust ist definitiv keine Sprache die man einfach lesen kann
Und das ist noch schönes Rust, ich mein gut es ist nichts zu verglichen mit C++, C++
ist eh das ist der Teufel in Person was das angeht
Ach hier macht man, hier macht man das UI, view, row, new, spacing, align, items
Ok, also Leute wir müssen uns mal abklopfen, die wichtigsten Sachen die man bei einem Gui
Framework braucht beziehungsweise immer gucken kann ob es was taugt
Gibt es nen Webview und gibt es die Möglichkeit GPU beschleunigten Content einzubinden
Gibt es nen Webview, Browser
Moment das ganze Ding ist
Sofalle, jaja ich mach das öfters
Ok also nen Webview gibt es anscheinend schon mal net
Gibt es die Möglichkeit DirectX irgendwie einzubinden oder, oder
anscheinend ok keine Ahnung
Das muss ich mir mal angucken
Das macht nen echt interessanten Eindruck
Weil es fehlen wirklich ordentliche Cross Platform Gui Libraries
Es gibt kaum was, du hast aktuell so die Auswahl zwischen Pest und Cholera
Du kannst Qt mit C++ machen oder noch nen Python Unterbreiter mit Bundle
Oder du machst Elektron, das war's
Deswegen hoffe ich ja auch auf Flutter, dass die da was ordentliches abliefern
Mobile sieht schon wieder besser aus
Ok mal angenommen ich möchte Markdown HTML Content rendern hier drin
Wie würd ich das machen?
HTML
Kann man HTML drin rendern?
Man weiß es nicht
Wobei die Docs ja auch ein bisschen
Die Docs ein bisschen sehr
Gewöhnungsbedürftig sind
Ja
Es freuen sich alle darauf, dass ich so viele Einsteppe in der Browser Bar gerade
habe
Ne das ist WebAssembly oder was anderes
Vielleicht sollte man das mal ausprobieren
Also ich finde nicht, dass da drinnen steht ob es ein Webview gibt
Build in Widgets
Cross Platform Support
Aber ob es ein Build in Webview gibt
Sehe ich da jetzt nicht
Jetzt wirst du es nie wieder nicht mehr sehen können
Ja
Das war's für heute.